todos los asistentes están en modo de solo escucha
qué tal muy buenas tardes como estáis
os saluda sergi sánchez
una clase más del curso de trading algorímico
así que vamos a comenzar
con ello
creo que me habéis como siempre voy a escribirlo
buenas
se me oye
que me oís ya veo que me oís porque me estáis contestando
pero si alguien no me oye pues ya lo ya lo he escrito
ya lo he escrito por ahí
vale
como siempre empezamos atendiendo un poquito las
las preguntas que hay en el
sobre todo en el disc or
también voy a hacer algún comentario algún
algún email
y luego vamos a trabajar
para enseñaros cositas
ideas que hemos trabajado bastante en profundidad
durante esta
durante esa semana
vale a ver el disco
el disco que está
bueno ya ha visto ya lo que habíamos dejado comentado
pero aquí antes
voy la verdad que comentabas aquí en el disco que no
conseguías que te genera ningún trade y pues
que la idea no te sé
no te sé decir con los datos que pones ahí la verdad
tienes
la de arriba está en status on la de abajo está en status off
no sé
no sé si alberto se le ocurre algo que pueda provocar
que la estrategia no opere bueno
quizá en la sesión que lo tenga en el horario local a lo mejor cargado el símbolo
pudiera ser
pudiera ser fíjate que lo tengas cargado en exchange
el símbolo vale te enseño
lo que lo que quiero decir
espera que vamos a sacar ya esto
enseño lo que quiero
a decir
vale es decir tu cuando cargas un símbolo en el gráfico
a
puedes elegir aquí local o exchange vale dependiendo
del tipo de sistema
si tú usas horas
e y tú te refieres a time
por ejemplo pues es time ese
es la hora del gráfico
entonces tú le has puesto 9 30 y el gráfico
va de 15 30 a 10 de la noche que es lo que te pasa en este caso como yo lo tenía
ahora en el local lo que pasa que este este sistema en concreto
lo veremos más adelante es un volatilidad y breakout no es uno es rebe
por lo tanto no usa horas y no importa
pero si tú usas horas
pues puedes se puede provocarte eso que no opere vale que no opere porque pues
la hora no existe si tú le dices a partir de las 9 30 hace x cosa y es ahora
no está en el gráfico
pues ese puede ser un motivo vale
se me ocurre que se puede ser eso es probable que sea eso es probable que sea
eso porque
ya te digo es algo usual ahora ahora he caído vale bien que más
comentaba Juan Manuel
ya las de favor quedó la semana pasada voy voy leyendo
respecto a la configuración del money management para el sistema durante la
evaluación para saber qué exposición neta del sistema en porcentaje se
recomienda por consenso para el aparancamiento y cómo establecerlo en
código bueno no hay una recomendación de aparancamiento no aparancamiento eso es
algo
que depende de muchísimos factores desde uno personal vale es el riesgo o sea en
evaluación preliminar y lo que os comenté es que nosotros aunque también
os lo dije y os digo levantó que sigue habiendo cierto debate sobre el tema es
decir nosotros ya ya os explicó siempre os he intentado explicar las cosas que
que digamos la industria pues tiene ya establecidas y cosas que al final
hacemos nosotros porque nosotros las queremos así entonces por haber
distintas opiniones
nosotros creemos que es mejor usar
un money management pero es verdad que si tú tienes el gráfico ajustado si tú
tus esto se ajustan a la volatilidad te puedes o sea no es grave de acuerdo no es
grave que vaya todo el rato con un con un contrato pero es importante que se
ajuste y aún así habrán el ejemplo del nasda que es el que pusimos en el curso
es muy paradigmático no porque la variación de precios si miras en muy
largo plazo es es bestial y claro un contrato del 2000 no es un contrato del
2009 y mucho menos el 2024 entonces si tú todo el rato vas con un contrato pues
ese es el problema entonces realmente usamos un money management que
simplemente permita que esos contratos varíen el que estáis viendo hasta ahora
en estos ejercicios que hemos hecho en la práctica es anominal vale que es
este tengo aquí un sistema que os enseñaré luego bueno igual de hecho da
igual porque no tengo todos iguales vale aquí simplemente usamos el importe
que le ponemos nosotros en la cuenta se multiplica por un multiplicador que es
100 vale que por cien vale lo único que está separado el dinero inicial la
cuenta inicial y el que vas ganando pero al final le ponemos cien iguales y la
realidad no está separado es lo mismo porque en ambos casos multiplicamos por
cien y lo sumamos vale por lo tanto queda que da igual y eso se divide por
un valor que al final es el cierre multiplicado por big point value vale
que es el cierre multiplicado por big point value el valor nominal de un
activo vale es decir en este caso yo estoy invirtiendo este este money
management que ves tú equivale a ir a 100% de exposición vale es eso pero
simplemente es porque para para mirar un poco cómo va el sistema pues pues
usamos uno sencillo que no tiene mucha mucha historia en las prácticas
probablemente a partir de la de cuando acabemos ya este este volatilidad
breakout o revés y demás que confío que va a ser hoy
entonces seguramente abordaremos algunas clases como llamarlas temáticas de
no solo de hacer un sistema aunque en los ejemplos pues se pueden hacer
sistemas pero pues ya ya lo comenté durante la teoría y también lo he hecho
en las prácticas pues por ejemplo busqueda de ideas por ejemplo
el aprovechando en la revisión que hemos hecho de apolo que lo comenté y
ha habido algún comentario en el disco estoy de acuerdo que es interesante pues
haremos una práctica de eso mirar un sistema real se sale de su zona los
revisamos ponemos un poco esta práctica de un caso real de la revisión de un
sistema que está operando entiendes entonces porque creo realmente que es
algo que puede aportar mucho mucho mucho valor
y por supuesto que salvo que iba ahora gestión monetaria
ahondaremos en la gestión monetaria de manera específica, lógicamente con
ejemplos prácticos, pero que la clase estará más enfocada en la gestión
monetaria que en el hecho de hacer un sistema como por ejemplo hoy, que
estamos más enfocados en hacer un sistema.
¿Qué más? Entonces volviendo un poco a tus preguntas,
entonces ya te digo, ese Money Management no deja de ser instrumental un poquito
para que no estés todo el rato con un contrato y te adaptes a los distintos
precios a lo largo del activo. ¿Se puede ajustar a la volatilidad? Sí,
pero ya digo, el Money Management como tal para operar en la práctica uno lo
hemos visto y sí, en estas prácticas que te comentaba ahora pues lo
veremos, lo veremos y ahí sí que lo ajustamos a la volatilidad y sí que os
enseñaremos lo que hacemos nosotros que al final, pues bueno, sí, tiene algún
detalle propio, pero que como ya os comenté, la teoría se basa en Fixed Risk,
el único, podemos decir, particularidad que tú tienes y mucha gente lo hace así,
es decir, es como mides risk, de acuerdo, como mides risk, es decir, al final
el risk va en el denominador y ya lo veremos y pueden haber varias formas de hacerlo,
a ver un segundo, estará Alex aquí con la música a todo trapo.
La rebelión de las máquinas ya llegará ya, bueno, entonces doy esto por
respondido, también preguntabas, una vez tenemos un sistema en Live or Paper, ¿cómo
crear y gestionar un backtest report de los datos live en nuestro sistema de los
test efectuados? No te termino de entender, a ver, no entiendo, no sé si tú lo
entiendes Alberto, pero lo entiendo, me refiero a la pregunta 2, sigo con la
tercera, vale, si la entiendes me lo dices, luego dice que tiene dudas sobre
the sleep page, no, realmente siempre usamos la misma forma, es verdad que
TrayStation, aunque hizo un cambio hace mucho, ha cambiado un poco en eso, lo que
pasa es que cambia básicamente dependiendo del tipo de activo, vale, tú
cuando multichats, por ejemplo, es un poco más completo y a la vez complicado, pero
más completo, vale, porque te permite hacer como unas plantillas de comisiones,
aquí realmente tienes un sitio para fijar la comisión y un sitio para
fijar el sleep page, vale, la comisión es lo que evolucionaron y al final, veis, te
lo explica, por trade, por acción, vale, al final, no importa qué pones, son dólares, si
tú le pones por trade, son cinco dólares por cada trade, independientemente, si le
pones por acción, pues cinco dólares por cada acción, total cost, esto es un
porcentaje total del coste, por si quieres imputar un porcentaje, no, esta es
una parte en fija dólar y una parte en porcentaje de coste, de acuerdo, es decir,
al final es bastante auto-explicado, si no, como siempre, la ayuda, aunque ahora
mismo recuerdo si esta parte es realmente está muy explicada, la mayoría
de partes están muy explicadas, bueno, aquí te explican poco, pero tampoco veo
que profundicen, ya digo, cuando ves ahí 001 es porque esto es una acción, el
SPY, por lo tanto, le penalizamos 001 dólares por acción, que es un TIC,
es un TIC, o sea, aquí casi siempre hay un TIC, cuando es un futuro dices, bueno, es que a
veces veo 10, claro, es que el TIC son 10, de acuerdo, esto depende de cuánto es el
TIC, básicamente, nosotros solemos poner per selección y aquí nuevamente
ponemos un TIC, TIC y medio, dos TICs, sería un poco ya el límite, también depende
del futuro, si pones el IBEX, a lo mejor tienes que poner tres TICs, aquí no puede ser
el IBEX, pero ya me entiendes, entonces depende un poco de los de los futuros,
normalmente un TIC, un TIC y medio, es bastante pesimista realista y la
comisión la que sea, que no tiene más, este era por, le he puesto porque tres
TICs en modo internacional tiene cinco dólares por trade y se lo he puesto en la realidad, lo cobra
tres TICs y un TIC, un TIC de penalización y eso que cierra es limitado, o sea, que realmente
este podría ponerle menos, podría ponerle menos, vale, bueno, los ratios, si despliega, me has
preguntado varias veces, no sé, lo iremos viendo, el TSI, es que depende del tipo de
sistema, vale, es decir, hay tipos de sistema que lo normal es moverse en 2.000, 3.000 y
hay que se mueven más, lo explico, es decir, el TSI nuevamente se mueven miles, vale, podemos
entender, la expectancia es que normalmente se mueve en unidades tres, pero cuando es un diario
pues ya es más grande, es que depende, porque al final no deja de ser fórmulas que se calculan
dependiendo del valor del beneficio, del beneficio por trade, del draudar, entonces depende si hay
gestión monetaria, si no la hay, vale, es decir, lo que importa ahí cuando hablamos de TSI, estas
cosas en los informes de optimización es un ejercicio de comparación, si te lias y no lo ves
claro mira un poco el profit factor que sí que está, podemos decir, bastante normalizado y ya
sabemos que se va a mover pues en dos, tres, en uno y pico, de acuerdo, es decir, es un poco
donde se va a mover, de acuerdo, el profit factor es el que te puede decir un poco si vas de manera
intuitiva por buen camino o no, vale. La comparación del char, sí, esta es buena, sí, esto te lo
explico porque, sí, bueno, leo la pregunta, leo la pregunta porque esta es buena, es algo que por
experiencia sé que genera bastantes dudas y problemas, vale, la configuración del chart para
la construcción de vela natural o session hours cual elegir y si es relevante, esto se está refiriendo
a quien interese eso pero ya digo, puede aplicar y aplica a otras plataformas, cuando yo tengo un
gráfico entre diario, no es el caso pero lo pongo ahora aquí, tengo aquí, se me abren unas opciones
que me dice for bar building use natural hours o session hours, vale, esto es importante fijaros
que por ejemplo en visual chart cuando teníamos el fondo nos generaba muchos problemas porque
ellos van en natural hours, es decir, ellos no tienen la concepción de tres session de sesiones
donde yo voy aquí y puedo controlar la sesión del símbolo dependiendo del horario y demás,
porque hay futuros pues que su sesión no va en un día natural, en el caso del spy como este
que estáis viendo, pues sí, va de sus 9.30 a sus 4 de la tarde pero el globex pues va de 11 de 12
a 11, puede coger dos días en muchos casos, entonces para este tipo de cosas es donde aplica
esto, esto lo que quiere decir es si para construir la vela, imagínate que tienes una vela de 7
minutos porque la puedes tener, no tienes ninguna limitación en ese sentido, puedes poner velas de
86 y si quieres en segundos también de 83 segundos, entonces te dice, vale, yo cómo la hago la vela,
me baso en el horario natural, que es horario natural, pues de las 12 de la noche, es decir,
yo empezaría a construir independientemente de la sesión, vale, de la sesión que es otro tema,
él empezaría a construir las velas de, imagínate, 7 minutos a las 12.00, por lo tanto la primera
sería a las 12.07, la siguiente sería a las 12.14, la siguiente a las 12.21 y así, vale,
en cambio si yo le pongo empezar a construir por session hours, que es lo más habitual y más
recomendable, imagínate este caso el spike empieza a 9.30, vale, cuál será la primera vela, pues la
primera vela será 9.37, vale, se entiende, será 9.37, si yo hubiera elegido natural hours sería la
que le tocara, teniendo en cuenta que él hacer el cálculo, aunque el activo empiece 9.30, el
cálculo lo empieza a hacer a las 12, entonces a las 9.30 ahora mismo no sé cuál le tocaría,
pero habría que ver cuál le tocaría, porque él empezaría a construir las velas a las 12.00,
es decir, horario natural, vale, horario natural, esta es la diferencia, en muchos casos no te va
a afectar, porque si tú usas velas de 30 y realmente el activo empieza a una hora en punto,
que es lo normal, no empiezan al mercado a las 9.37, empiezan a las 9.30, empiezan a las 8.00,
empiezan a las 9.00, entonces da igual, pero si usaras un time frame distinto, pues sí que podría
afectarte, y a nosotros con el oro, que lo hemos operado muchas veces en time frames extraños,
ahora operamos en 28, pero lo hemos operado en otros, pues podía afectar, y luego en el volumen
es un poco lo mismo, si usa, esto te lo explica mejor aquí, y es un poco largo, porque prefiero
no meterme en ese vergenal, porque es un tema sobre todo de programación, es un tema sobre todo
de programación, de hecho hay una tabla en los libros Easy Language, y aquí también, a ver si
ahora la encuentro, pensaba que por aquí llegaría fácil, aquí hay língua en la tabla, bueno, aquí te
dice esta simplificación, pero es que realmente hay un matiz, dependiendo si cargas un entradí,
además, o un diario, y luego si cargas, que depende qué activo, y hay una tabla, pero bueno,
en términos generales, por simplificar, es lo que lo que te dice aquí, de acuerdo, si straightball
simplemente es lo obvio, con cuenta acciones, y acciones o futuros, que se cambian de manos,
y el tick out lo que hace es contar los traits, que es lo que es un tick, un tick al final es un
trait, es un trait, independientemente del número de acciones que tenga lugar, normalmente usamos
straightball, pero hay un, ya digo, no veo ahora aquí ese enlace, es igual, es un tema más de
programación, y que sí que... estaría que no está aquí, porque era un tema que estaba en muchos
sitios, porque generaba problemas, pero ya digo, no os calentéis, que si no lo necesitáis, ya lo
veréis, aquellos que tengáis el libro VisiLanguage, veréis que en la parte final del libro hay una
tabla que habla de esto, ya está, quedaros con eso, discord que más, creo que ya estaba,
ah bueno, bien, Gabriel decía que era eso, lo del time, perfecto, sí, lo sé, lo sé, lo sé, lo sé,
lo sé, digo que también he aprovechado para leer la de Gabel que dice que era eso, la B2 se refería
a cómo crear un performance report de datos live para ver los fines estadísticas del sistema en
live, ha entendido, bueno, 3session tiene una función para eso, que es verdad que en determinados
momentos ha dado algunos problemas, sobre todo cuando hay multidivisas, si no, no hay tanto,
hay aquí un botón apps, que es el trade manager analysis, que eso hace un performance report de
la cuenta, entonces ahí lo puedes seguir, pero también te recomiendo que tú pues vayas llevando
tu propio lock, de acuerdo, bien del programa, bien con excel, bien con estas herramientas y si
ahora funciona bien, que nosotros ya digo ahora no la usamos, por lo tanto no te puedo decir,
y los puedes ir cogiendo del trade manager directamente, la verdad que eso sí que va
bien de copiar y pegar desde ahí a excel y tienes que ir un poco generándolo tú, generándolo tú,
nosotros solemos hacerlo así, solemos hacerlo directamente en excel, lo llevamos un poco por
nuestra cuenta, pero ya digo, esa realmente está ahí y sé que había dado muchos problemas,
me dijeron que la había arreglado pero yo no lo he probado, pero esto de esto ya te digo, puedes
sacar performance report de la propia cuenta, o sea, de hecho es que si lo haces sale igual,
vale, no sé qué saldrá, porque no sé si habrá algún trade aquí simulador o no creo, no me suena,
no me acuerdo que haya habido alguno, pero ya digo, sale un performance report bastante parecido con
los trades y todo, pero ya digo del broker de la cuenta, es un poco lento, ahora no me va a dejarse
saberlo, que más, que más, que más, el max bar va en todos igual, el max bar es cuanto pregunta
también, perdón, pregunta Juan Manuel sobre el max bar settings, vale, esto es más de plataforma,
pero esto simplemente es el número de barras que necesita el sistema para calcular, es decir,
si tú vas a optimizar, si yo aquí tengo ese sistema y tiene esta media, por ejemplo, bueno,
aquí por ejemplo el sistema que luego lo veremos, tiene un número de barras, tiene un rango,
tiene una dx, una tr, bueno, pues si yo la media esta la voy a utilizar hasta 50, vale, pues al
max bar tengo que poner al menos 50 o 55 y ya está, sin más, no tiene mayor historia, vale,
lo tienes que poner aquí y ya está, le pones el valor que le quieras poner, o sea, que vayas a
ponerle más de optimizar, si te salta eso es porque tú le has pedido un cálculo más allá
de ese valor, esto es un indicador automático y el sistema no lo es, porque, pues, no sé, la verdad,
porque podría hacerlo, esta pestaña que comentas de si operas, lo normal es tenerlo activado,
si no lo puedes activar, si, vale, perdón, al revés, te lo he dicho al revés, vale, es decir,
si operas, de acuerdo, normalmente lo pones para que no recalcule, porque no te puede provocar un
problema que recalcule, si no lo puedes activar, porque entonces recalcula, vale, y entonces no sé
a qué te refieres, con qué soluciona, esto te ponías ahí aquellos de recomiendan quitarlo,
si lo puedes, lo puedes quitar de manera normal, de manera usual, pero bueno, operativa, pues si
operas directamente con la plataforma en live, pues es mejor activarlo, y en cuanto a la optimización
genética de esta, hay un par de, han habido ya varios comentarios al respecto, de hecho,
había alguna duda por aquí, alguien aquí que le salía eso, y me viene al pelo, porque el tema es
que hay veces que no vas a poder hacer genética, porque es absurdo, es decir, si tú el número de
combinaciones en exhaustivo es menor, que es lo que aparece en esta imagen, el mensaje no te dice,
el número de parámetros que has elegido es mayor que el de exhaustivo, entonces no tiene sentido
hacer la genética que está diciendo, es decir, hazla exhaustiva, entonces ese es el criterio,
os dije que es mejor genético para buscar zonas, evidentemente, si el número de inputs es tan
pequeño que no hay zonas, pues la haces exhaustiva, por ejemplo, para hacer mapas viene mejor exhaustiva,
viene mejor exhaustiva, porque no te interesa que hayan huecos, entonces al final es un poco
depende, dije que genética es buena por su propia manera de buscar valores, pero no quiere decir que
la exhaustiva sea mala, la exhaustiva es perfectamente válida y de hecho hay para cosas
que se usa, como por ejemplo el mapa, y si el tiempo te lo permite, pues hazla exhaustiva,
no tiene en sí nada especialmente negativo, ahora bien, si el tiempo es demasiado haz la genética,
que normalmente ya es suficiente, es decir, normalmente ya es suficiente, entonces más
que haya un umbral o no, es que técnicamente sea posible, vale, no tiene más historia, y acabando
aquí, y luego ya con otra email que nos han enviado, pero empezamos por esto, que nos dice que
por folio maestro el símbolo list vale, por folio maestro ya ha comentado varias veces,
de hecho hoy ha saltado un update que no lo he instalado, de hecho desde hace muy poco que
se pueden evitar las updates, hace poco ahora se puede y la he saltado, porque digo a ver si
le meto el update y no puedo hacer clases, entonces esto es por eso, por eso he hecho, pero
a ver qué cambios hay, no lo he visto, cuando tú en una strategy group quieres poner un
símbolo list es súper primitivo, entonces tú tienes los custom y los suyos, vale,
de los tres stations símbolo list, ahí sí que la mayoría de SPI, yo que sé, el SP, etcétera,
los vas a tener ahí, pero si no lo encuentras aún así no te queda otra, tienes industrias, etcétera,
aquí tienes los index components típicos, SP500, SP100, NASDAQ100, etcétera,
caujones, tiene los típicos, entre stations símbolo list y luego ya digo en index components o
en index vale, pero aún así muchas veces pues te haces tú las listas y no te queda otra que
hacértela y a veces la tienes que hacer hasta para un símbolo, porque pues si tú quieres a
mejor poner un símbolo solo con varios sistemas pues no te queda otra que hacer esto, hacer una
lista que se llame cuckoo y ponerle el cuckoo dentro, porque va por listas, va por listas,
es un poco tema, le das aquí a create manage list y las listas se comparten, si las has hecho
entre stations también están aquí, eso sí que es correcto, así que entiendo que con eso he
respondido a tu pregunta ¿no? ah bueno, no, el índice sí, no, no, estos los agrego, los agrego,
o sea los creo yo, o sea los DTF los tengo hechos, vale, y los DTF igual, no, no, no, no, yo no los
he encontrado tampoco, perdona que te lo vuelvo a mostrar, tú vas aquí, si te fijas ahí, custom
symbol list, vale, aquí create manage, vale, le das a create y te la creas, te creas una y la
añades, pero ya digo el interface es bastante más cómodo y más fácil entre station, porque desde
un radar skin los puedes seleccionar, pues al botón derecho y pones add symbol list, lo puedes
hacer, vale, entonces es bastante más friendly, desde aquí también puedes ir directamente a ver
si me acuerdo el shortcut, no, para que me acuerde, no, no eres aquí, no eres aquí, eres aquí quizá, exacto,
aquí tienes edit list, vale, y aquí sale, vale, desde el menú de gráfico del chart, desde aquí de
data, pero en un radar skin, lo que te digo, si tú tienes un radar skin abierto, que es la manera más
sencilla en mi opinión, y los escribes aquí, porque aquí los puedes escribir directamente, o sea tú
puedes tener, digamos, una lista y pegarla, pero puedes escribir en un radar skin, vale, tú puedes poner aquí
cú, cú, cú, vale, espérate, que está flamenco, tú le pones cú, cú, le pones spy, le pones euro
dólar, vale, le pones xlf, lo que me decías, lo que quieras, vale, y esto tú ahora lo seleccionas, vale,
y en data, no, edit symbol, append select symbol, custom symbol list, le das ahí, te abre la ventana y
ahí ya te la creas, vale, la puedes añadir a una o le creas una normal, no una histórica, vale, entonces
es más, y luego la encontrarás allí, entonces te pones uno, etf, son mis etf, o lo que tú quieras y te la
creas, esto es la manera más sencilla, vale, y él es bastante más intuitivo y más friendly, todo lo que
tiene a tres es eso que maestro, ya el interface mismo es un poco feo, vale, a manuel aboga en algún
detallito más, pregunta, si se hace genética se ve configurada a mano la configuración o vale,
no, dale el sugest, está bien, está bien, de verdad, no te compliques, no te compliques, de verdad,
no te compliques, el único caso donde tiene algún sentido es en el world forward, en el world
forward, vale, pero por lo demás, dale al sugest y es correcto, es correcto, vale, bien, vamos al
revés, antes de entrar en el revés, os comento una cosa, ya pido disculpas de antemano por saltarme
una regla propia que me había impuesto, de acuerdo, pero es por una buena causa, es por una buena
causa, por la buena causa que es al final, creo que va a ahondar en mejores clases para todos, vale,
cuando hicimos la encuesta, hicimos la encuesta diciendo, bueno, proponiendo varias fechas,
ganó el lunes, no de mucho de hecho, vale, y era lunes y el segundo día fue el martes, vale,
estamos viendo, estamos viendo que por logística es mucho mejor hacerla el martes que el lunes,
por logística nuestra, pero que como os digo acaba ahondando en mejor, creo que ahondará en
mejores clases, vale, porque el fin de semana tú, lógicamente las clases las preparamos durante
bastantes días, pero el fin de semana, aunque frecuentemente el sábado también yo preparo,
pero evidentemente alguno intentó que no y el domingo también intentó que no, entonces llega
el lunes y pues a lo mejor es desde el sábado o desde el viernes, además no está Alberto,
tienes el sábado quiero decir, entonces, bueno, es un poquito más, es un poquito,
o sea, nos creerá que el lunes tienes como un rato de resituarte, no, entonces esto se evita
haciendo el martes, entonces se evita haciendo el martes o cualquier otro día, pero como el
martes fue el segundo más votado, vale, el martes fue el segundo más votado, pues de ahí que
propongamos el martes, yo entiendo que no va a haber problemas, entiendo que no va a haber
problemas, pero si hay muchos problemas pues lo volveríamos a votar, pero yo entiendo que no,
porque ya digo que salió el segundo claramente, salió el lunes y martes y entonces pues ya digo,
si alguien, por los que las veis en directo más o menos, sois siempre los mismos, si alguien pues
tiene mucho inconveniente que lo comente, pero ya digo, como digo, es por una buena causa, entonces
lo damento porque, claro, hice una encuesta y era para que lo eligierais vosotros, pero
estamos viendo que va a ser mejor para las clases hacerlo el martes, si no, no lo cambiaría,
porque a mí como día me da igual, de acuerdo, no tengo ninguna predilección por el lunes o por
martes, el hecho es lo que os digo, que al hacerla en martes ya está el lunes antes, ya nos hemos
situado y tengo el lunes y el martes perfectamente disponibles y totalmente centrado para acabar de
preparar la clase como se merece, entonces ese es un poco el motivo. Sobre la pregunta Aureli,
si hay calendario de finalización, pues no Aureli, si te soy sincero no, porque realmente
vamos lentos, es la calidad y que es por mi manera de ser, no es culpa de nadie, entonces al final,
pues la verdad que creo que queda bastante, queda bastante, ya hemos hecho bastantes horas,
aunque no lo parezca, pero queda bastante, queda bastante, no sé decirte cuánto,
yo creo que a la que vayamos avanzando, pues empezaré a tener un poco más de visibilidad y
daremos un, y así que trataremos de afinar, no decir, oye, pues yo creo que pueden quedar cinco,
pueden quedar siete, pero ahora mismo no soy capaz, Aureli, te lo estoy honesto, no soy capaz de
decirte si quedan cinco, quedan diez, no sé, de verdad, no lo sé, porque mi sensación es que
hemos hecho muy poca cosa, entiendes, entonces todavía en las prácticas, esa es la sensación que
tengo, que hemos hecho poca cosa, seguimos, de acuerdo, seguimos, más Semana Santa, más allá,
hombre, no, eso es seguro, más allá de marzo, seguro que eso ya es, ya es, ya, o sea, Semana
Santa es ya, entonces si ahora las pasamos a martes, pues nada, seguimos en martes, en principio,
bueno, no sé, no tengo ahora el calendario aquí delante, bueno, tengo el pequeñito este,
pero si no tengo el outlook, bueno, si lo tengo, espérate, cambio de ventana y un nombre, no,
Semana Santa ya sé, pero Semana Santa no es festival martes, no, es decir, Semana Santa es
festival, es festival, sí, sí, a ver, yo no tenía intención de parar, la verdad, porque si ya digo,
es que si no se va con lo que nos queda, yo, en principio ya digo, los martes no veo ningún
martes festivo, así que en principio, en principio, salvo algún impedimento personal,
pues no hay ningún motivo para no hacerla, bueno, para normal, no voy a entrar en valoraciones,
valoraciones, bueno, bien, entonces ya está, en principio ya digo, si alguien que los llame,
lo que sea, pero creamos que aún no están cambiado el resto, esta sí que la cambiamos,
porque ayer nos iba muy mal a hacerla, pero pues también ya se abría, ya nosotros ya durante la
semana pasada empezamos a ver esto y hemos visto esta semana que es muy claro, es muy claro y es
mucho mejor para la clase que sea martes que lunes, porque ya digo, nos da más margen para
trabajarla mejor, esa es la realidad, vale, entonces, vale, bien, por ejemplo, se me han enviado un
trabajo, aprovecho, voy a aprovechar tu trabajo, bueno, como lo has enviado a privado, tampoco lo
enseño, pero me viene bien un poco para comentar algunas cosas, vale, algunas cosas, basado en
este reto que puso Rupert Tacho de un típico ORB, pues intentó trabajar algunos filtros que de hecho
vamos, algunos de los que probaste también los vamos a ver hoy y comentaba, comentaba Zenén que
le resultó muy complicado, bueno, tan complicado que no consiguió obtener en el lado largo algo
interesante, de acuerdo, bueno, no, un poco lo decía como una extrañeza, es raro, pero no es tan
raro, porque al final tú con un volatility breakout tal como lo hemos definido hasta ahora,
que por supuesto es opcional, todo es opcional en un sistema, es decir, nosotros fijamos que a la
fin de día, pero podías quedarte, entonces cambia todo, entonces cambia completamente, si tú te quedas
a más de un día, digamos, pero lo tratamos de plantear así, de esta manera, claro, tú estás
operando un activo que es el que estáis viendo hoy en pantalla, que es el SPI, que es, yo diría que
un poco alcista, de largo plazo, es un poco alcista de largo plazo, que lógicamente tiene sus
períodos bajistas, pero en el largo plazo es un poco alcista, subido un poco, subido un poco,
entonces, claro, cualquier cosa que frene, que vaya contra esa tendencia, esto puede
parecer contraintuitivo, pero verás que no lo es, vale, es complicado y entonces tú dices,
claro, pero a mí eso me hace pensar que es más fácil ganar en el largo que en el corto,
y sí que lo es, pero si quitas la restricción de cerrar a fin de día, entiendes, si quitas
la restricción de cerrar a fin de día, porque acuérdate que el mercado sube con poca volatilidad
y baja con mucha volatilidad, tú justamente lo que estás buscando es un volatility breakout,
entiendes, entonces, claro, al alza hay menos volatilities breakouts, hay mucha tendencia,
hay mucho seguimiento de tendencia, hay mucha subida, pero no necesariamente volatilities
breakouts, en cambio abajo es todo lo contrario, abajo es relativamente sencilla, aunque parezca
contraintuitivo, pillar roturas de volatilidad porque el mercado cuando cae, cae con volatilidad,
de acuerdo, es verdad que no es fácil, ¿por qué? porque la tendencia de fondo prevalece y por lo
tanto tienes que buscar, como ya has hecho tú y por eso también estamos limitados en intradía,
pues objetivos cercanos, ¿de acuerdo? ¿por qué? porque al final cuando tú tienes la tendencia en
contra, pues ahí es mejor ir rápido, ¿de acuerdo? salir rápido, en cambio en el lado largo verás
que te resultará mucho más sencillo si eliminas la restricción de cerrar a fin de día, entonces
verás que es muy fácil encontrar roturas de volatilidad, porque entonces ya renta, ¿de acuerdo?
deja correr más, porque la mayoría de sesiones al alza, me refiero cuando el mercado entra en una
tendencia alcista, imagínate este tramo aquí, mira esto, este que luego a lo largo de la clase
lo veremos, esto es un volatilities breakout al uso, que está tal como está, yo creo que es
decente, ¿de acuerdo? que es decente y verás que se también gana en el largo y en el corto, pero gana
más en el corto, gana más en el corto, ¿vale? y también buscando entradas muy rápidas y demás,
pero este entra en corrección, ¿de acuerdo? busca la volatilities breakout, pero tras corregir,
muy habitual en sistemas de acciones, ¿de acuerdo? de hecho, por ejemplo Artemisa hace eso, Artemisa
hace eso, ¿de acuerdo? es algo, lo que no es tan rápido es saliendo como este, pero porque este
busca solo el breakout y se sale, ¿de acuerdo? cambiar Artemisa, digamos que su setup de entrada
es de este estilo, pero se queda, ¿vale? lo que te decía un poco ahora, ¿no? entonces ya digo,
si te quedas es más fácil, entonces no es tan raro, no es tan raro como te parece por el hecho
de obligarle a salir a fin de día y porque el mercado sube con poca volatilidad, aún así es
posible, aún así es posible, no digo que no sea posible, pero es más complicado si no te quedas,
de hecho por ejemplo en los libros de Krabbel tenía varios apuntes donde no todo el mundo
plantea los volatilities breakouts o los ORB para ir a un sub-tipo obligatoriamente cerrando a fin
de día, ¿de acuerdo? eso es una, de hecho en nuestro código había un input que lo controlaba,
pero sí que es verdad que yo hasta ahora lo he dejado bloqueado en uno, pero que podías plantearlo
y darle dos o darle tres o darle dos o también podías trabajar otra variante porque ahora voy
a hablar un poco de las distintas filtros y demás, vamos a trabajar un poco en eso y de verdad
es el mundo es infinito los filtros, pero ahora se me ocurre uno que de hecho no hemos trabajado,
que es que dependiendo del día de la semana que entres quedarte o no quedarte, ¿de acuerdo?
quedarte o no quedarte, esto tiene mucho sentido, es muy importante el sentido común en los
vídeos porque si no, no se acaba nunca, tú le puedes poner 74 filtros al semana, no hay que
hacerlo, entonces hay que usar pocos pero coherentes, entonces este es muy coherente,
este es muy coherente, dependiendo del día de la semana cerrar a fin de día o no,
si es lunes, martes, miércoles, jueves o viernes cerrar a fin de día o no,
y de hecho tenía yo por aquí ya que he comentado esto, enseñaron un gráfico que no sé si
encontraré creo que las reuniones estaba verdad Alberto lo de aquel gráfico que teníamos de los
días, ¿de acuerdo? es muy guapo aquello, si las reuniones estaban, ahora lo encuentro de un momento
entre una y dos horas yo creo que llegó él, ahí está, ahí está, ya lo tengo, ahí lo veis,
a ver si esto es el retorno de el overnight, el overnight en SP, ahora no recuerdo en qué año
está hecho, esto es de sentiment trader, el overnight por día de la semana, veis las enormes
diferencias, ya os la pasaré esa imagen, y lo mismo pero durante el daytime, la sesión normal,
es decir este que veíamos ahora de 9.34 que sigue siendo bastante heavy, el viernes el más lojo,
el miércoles el mejor y se pueden combinar uno de otro, mejor diurno, aquí tenemos algunas notas,
estrategias nuestras analizadas, esto no deja de ser un blog de notas donde tomamos notas,
pero a raíz de esto, lo que os decía, imaginaros, dependiendo si yo sé que es martes, si yo sé que
estoy en el operando el martes y sé que el nocturno del martes es el mejor nocturno que hay,
pues a lo mejor me cierro en la apertura de miércoles, por ejemplo, me lo acabo de inventar,
pero me entendéis ahí, cosas de este tipo, vale, entonces, vamos a ver un poquito todo el tema de
los filtros, ya he comentado lo que quería comentarle a Zenén, era esto verdad, no tenía
nada más, comentaba el del, bueno él comentaba que le había quedado un sistema bastante decente
de cortos, estoy de acuerdo lo que has enseñado ahí, además él decía que había seguido un
procedimiento paso a paso, variable a variable y demás, pues es interesante, es interesante,
sí que veo que tienes tu take profit en dólares, ya sabéis que no soy amigo de ello, pero oye,
ningún problema, quiero decir que muchos grandes autores lo usan, aunque ya os he comentado que no
estoy de acuerdo, creo que se están haciendo trampas al solitario, pero oye, al final,
como te decía antes en otro tema, esto hay opiniones, hay cosas que son bastante claras,
hay cosas que hay debate y os los explico, al final, tenéis que encontrar, en eso insisto mucho,
vuestra manera, evidentemente lo que nosotros decimos son cosas que no son tonterías,
que son correctas, pero tenéis que encontrar vuestra manera, vuestra manera al final puede
ser, pues debe ser distinta a la nuestra, poco a poco, vale, entonces el, a ver, aquí Alberto,
bueno, 1rb al final tiene tres partes, a ver dónde empiezo, en el world el rb04,
empiezo mejor ahí, o qué, ahí voy bien, con el de, bueno, ya iré yendo de uno a otro y está,
es que el de los filtros, el que tengo, el otro de análisis filtros que hiciste para hacer los
excel, está bastante guapo, yo casi lo veo más gráfico ahí, para enseñarlo digo, pero en el otro
al final está el código y eso es muy poco legible para alguien, el código es poco, sabes lo que te
voy a decir, es poco legible, bueno, al final, al final el rb tiene tres partes, la más obvia y más
clara es su rango y sus horas, que desata el setup de entrada, vale, ya vimos esto, a ver que voy
a abrir, a ver, lo que no tengo abierto es el wasp, a ver, dame un segundo, que tengo esto,
tener cuatro monitores, es a veces un poco, un poco excesante, por un lado tengo este con los
y por otro, este es el rango de inicio de sesión, no me hace falta, me pongo el del DAX, espera, acabo
que abre este, porque si no me va a reventar, me va a reventar, como le de al otro me va a reventar,
así que, el de inicio de sesión, vale, vale, bueno, voy a abrir ese primero, no, no, no pasa nada,
es que, es que la, para que veáis, para que veáis, todo esto es solo del rb, todo esto es solo
material del rb, artículos, estudios, optimizaciones que hemos hecho, los artículos que os pasamos,
a ustedes aquí, en fin, hay bastante lo de krabbel, hay un poco lío, bastante material,
y hemos hecho un trabajo bastante, bastante intenso, bastante intenso, a ver si ha acabado,
no ha acabado, bueno, pues nada, cuando tenga bien a acabar, es normal que tarde mucho esto, Alberto,
vale, vale, pero es el de, es el del Xiaomi, ya lo ves, no, no, pero el dedicado, no quiero
enseñar la IP, hombre, que al final es un lío, es hombre, yo creo que está tardando demasiado,
está waiting for data, aún, yo creo que se ha bugueado, eso cuando estoy conectado ya se buguea
con facilidad, porque, claro, estoy gastando muchos recursos ya para emitir, yo confío que,
porque es que, de verdad, esta última versión, no sé, es muy instable, ahora cuando acabe la
clase actualizaremos y a ver si hay alguna mejora, supongo que saltará si no se ha saltado ya,
si alguien lo ha probado que nos diga, porque la verdad que las últimas semanas las, no, no,
este es el que tenía yo, este es el que tenía yo, estoy cerrando, estoy cerrando, estoy cerrando,
porque de verdad que está muy poco estable, a ver, de momento tengo uno abierto aquí,
se me ha quedado el TSRTA server, se me ha quedado abierto, y no tengo nada abierto,
vale, ahora se ha ido, por cierto, si alguien tiene multicharts, multicharts ha sacado la
versión 15 ayer, todavía lo hemos probado, y tiene el replay, tiene el replay de mercado,
hay gente que le gusta mucho eso, el replay de mercado, sí, sí, sí, pero es muy fácil Alberto,
es que ya al darle se va a ver, que es el replay, no, no se llama el replay de mercado,
se llama playback o algo así, o sea, es hacer pasar el pasado como si fuera presente,
entiendes, es decir, reproducir el mercado, incluso operarlo, vale, yo ahora en el sistemático
igual, eh, en el sistemático no sé qué gran ventaja, qué gran ventaja tiene, pero, o sea,
puedes hacer paper trading de verdad, o sea, no hacer porque hubiera pasado, sino reproducir
otra vez la sesión de ayer, por ejemplo, entiendes, te pones la sesión de ayer y reproduces,
pero el tiempo es real, eh, bueno, pero en forest tester no hace exactamente eso, no, lo hace igual,
no la conozco solo de nombre, sí, sí, bueno, es eso, es eso, es para ver si se ejecuta bien,
el tema es que cuidado, hay que ver que lo reproduzca bien, al final, o sea, tampoco pensemos que lo
único que reproduce de verdad bien es la realidad, todo lo demás es, entiendes, no dejan de ser,
o sea, eso no deja de simular algo, vale, me explico, con lo cual, vale, por muy bien hecho que esté,
que lo, no lo sé, pero vamos a suponer que sí, al final está reproduciendo el pasado, no está,
hay cosas que no sé si las puede simular por mucho que, aunque ellos dicen que simula hasta el nivel
dos, eh, con lo cual parece que está muy bien hecho, parece que está muy bien hecho, sí, sí, ya lo sé,
que Ninja lo hace, pero repito, o sea, una cosa es reproducir el histórico y otra cosa es simular
la ejecución de órdenes, me explico, es decir, que por mucho que lo simulen muy bien, que seguro
que lo hacen, no, no debe ser igual, eh, pues no sé, Alberto, yo creo que esto está, está con todo algo, eh,
no tiene, no tiene normal, lo sabes, es muy potente, no puede ser esto, sí, pero no, nunca tarda tanto,
nunca tarda tanto, y además que los, está waiting for data, sabes, o sea, no, piensa que el otro lo
abierto y lo abre, o sea, no, a ver el otro, el que me has hecho el otro, bueno, pues igual se ha quedado
bugueado el, el, el servidor de datos, porque es realmente extraño, es que además lo tengo cacheado
todo esto, Alberto, sabes, o sea, es que está en caché, no, está bugueado el, el access layer,
porque esto está cacheado, eh, cien por cien, abro el mío ahora, que es de diario, y es, lo abre directo,
lo abre directo, bueno, pues nada, pues nada, ahí lo tenemos, venga, ya lo tienes, ahí, se acopla,
cuando te acercas, se acopla, se acopla, venga, toma un poco el servidor, venga, ya está, bueno,
vamos a ver, eh, todo esto, bien, basados en distintas fuentes, en varias de las que habéis visto de
Krabber, eh, también a un otro artículo, uno también desde el que he sacado este sistema,
el sistema que luego os enseñaré, que es un volatility breakout, no un ORB, que es un subtipo
de volatility breakout, eh, que os lo dimos el otro día, eh, este os lo dimos, os lo dimos el otro día,
a ver que lo abra, eh, que lo abra, eh, a ver, venga, se les dice entre aquí, nuevos artículos, aquí,
vale, aquí, vale, este es interesante, bueno, todos, todos los que os pasamos son interesantes,
por eso os los pasamos, no, por eso os los pasamos, pero bueno, ese es el original, yo, nosotros tratamos
de pasaros una, un resumen y demás, no, eh, pero bueno, había, había este también, que es, eh,
designing volatility breakout system, y bueno, hace una explicación básica de lo general, que es lo
que estaba diciendo ahora, es que no tiene, o sea, un volatility breakout, o decimos acá atrás, son
fabas juntadas, vale, porque sí que es verdad que en el, en el campo del filtro, en los ORBs,
donde especialmente está la clave, vale, ¿por qué?, porque al final, eh, tienes que marcar de alguna
manera, porque al final tú aquí ves sesiones, sesiones, sesiones, ¿de acuerdo?, y dices bueno,
lo fácil es, que es lo fácil, es lo intuitivo, es decir, pues bueno, un ranquito, yo ahí en sus roturas
opero, vale, bien, es una solución, en algunos activos puede funcionar, pero en la mayoría,
directamente así, como que falta algo, vale, y que falta, bueno, pues falta algún filtro que,
mirando lo que ha pasado en las anteriores sesiones, puede ser que el anterior, puede ser que a veces
algunas más, aumente las probabilidades de que la rotura de este día sea favorable, vale, es tan
fácil como eso. ¿En qué se basan esas, esos filtros?, bien, en la, en el que vimos de base había
uno típico de tendencia, Momentum, es decir, si el precio está mayor que N, pues este, en esta
versión que había del, del modelo de Rupert Tacho era este, vale, simplemente el cierre, el cierre es
mayor que un precio de referencia, que es el cierre diario de 14 días, esto que es un Momentum,
vale, es decir, el precio está subiendo, viene subiendo, vale, otro que implementamos en el
nuestro, ahora ya estamos en la versión 4, que es la que hoy vamos a usar, pero bueno, más o menos,
el final de la estructura es la misma, basado en un filtro de tendencia, de acuerdo, una media de
cierres diarios también, que esté por encima de esa media, pues eso encajaría en los filtros de
Momentum, vale, pero los que suelen ser más eficaces son los que hablan un poco de la pauta,
de la estructura del mercado, vale, de la estructura del mercado y la estructura muchas veces se mira
mejor en el gráfico diario, que lo tenéis aquí debajo, que lo voy a poner un poco más, que en el
propio intradía, donde vas a hacer el trade, ¿Cómo? Sí, sí, lo veo, lo veo, lo veo, lo veo, vale, y esto,
pues hay, como os digo, muchas figuras, Krabbel habrá de varias, las más conocidas son, por las que
habréis oído hablar, el Narrow Range, vale, que está, Serén, por ejemplo, que hablaba, él le había
usado, ahora no recuerdo si de 4 o de 7, Krabbel hablaba bastante de esto, un Narrow Range, ahora lo
vamos, lo voy a poner ya, esto hemos hecho, bueno, concretamente lo ha hecho Alberto, pero
es un indicador, que es un show me, que pinta velas, que pinta con puntitos las velas, para hacer
este tipo de cosas viene, viene muy bien, lo que me lo ha puesto todo, ah, vale, yo le pongo aquí el que
es, ¿no? Así que esto me va a ayudar tu más Alberto, que, bueno, es el documento este de Ana,
filtros del 1 al 6, no, el documento este yo tengo hasta 11, el otro no, este, pero ese tengo
al revés, el que te decía, pero este no sirve, ese ves, así se vele muy bien, tienes, grita, guay,
otra vez aquí, el código del EasyLanguage del show me en mi PC no debe estar, si está, perfecto,
pues vamos a abrir eso y lo iremos sobre, sobre código, iremos sobre código, a ver donde tengo
yo escrito, guardame tienes el código, no, tampoco está como te digo, no, venga, pues vamos con el
case 1, el case 1 habrá que ir interpretando cada uno, venga, me lo pongo, os lo voy diciendo yo,
porque si no, filtro tendencia es el input, el switch es elección filtro, vale, el case es
el elección filtro, el filtro tendencia debe servir para alguno de ellos, solo no, exacto,
si, ese está en el artículo, es correcto, vale, pues empezamos por el 1, que empezamos por el 1,
y allá vamos, empezamos en uno que me lo está marcando casi todo, estos son del artículo,
como me decías, verdad, si, ese es como el artículo, cierre mayor que la average, cierre
mayor que la average y hike mayor que hike anterior, vale, bien, este tipo de pautas que
hay, hay muchísimas, aquí solo en ese artículo hay algunas, vale, hay algunas, pero creo que
hay muchísimas, de acuerdo, hay muchísimas, aquí hay alguna que hemos mirado, ya os diremos
cuáles, hemos visto que van mejor, pero que hay muchísimas, de acuerdo, muchísimas, como os decía
antes también, los narrow range, los inside range, ya hablamos de ellos, también hay mucha gente que
tiene especificaciones para los gaps, hay distintas variaciones, hablaba antes de los días, cualquier
indicador de momentum, es decir, cualquier variación, vale, yo por ejemplo, siguiendo este artículo,
he utilizado también a brava, si no recuerdo mal, krabbel de ello, el ADX, aunque lo he hecho un
poco distinto a como lo hacía él, pero he utilizado al final el movimiento direccional, he utilizado
también la volatilidad, de acuerdo, al final son estos los vectores que hay, no hay más, lo que pasa
que sí que es verdad que la manera en que marcamos estas figuras, que nos hablan
un poco de la estructura de precio, son bastante definitoria, es decir, por mi experiencia lo que
más define que uno de rb acabe funcionando es este tipo de estructuras, de acuerdo, este tipo de
estructuras, que al final denotan, y como os digo, estructura de precios, vale, bien, esto como os
decía, lo hemos, lo Alberto lo ha programado en un show me, que cuando se cumple la condición lo marca,
como estáis viendo en el caso de la primera, pues es un filtro bastante al uso de tendencia,
nos fijáis en los tres ahora, que no importa, de hecho los voy a quitar, los voy a quitar los tres,
para no despistar, los voy a quitar, entonces al final no es más que el 1 es muy poco restrictivo,
esto os lo recomiendo muchísimo hacerlo, este código os lo pasaremos,
vale, para los que tengan este de station o multichars podéis importarlo, vale, esto os
recomiendo mucho porque ya en la teoría os hablaba de ello y que también os hablaba que me sorprende
porque he hablado con colegas que dicen que ellos miran pocos gráficos y a mí realmente me sorprende
muchísimo porque realmente es donde se ven las pautas, de acuerdo, donde se ven las pautas,
entonces al final por mucho que tú te puedas hacer una idea y ya sabes lo que es un cierre por
encima de una media y todo lo que queráis, de esta manera entiendes muy bien el filtro,
sabes, entiendes muy bien el filtro y le coges lo que os he hablado siempre de la sensibilidad,
vale, entonces es bastante útil, ves incluso a qué nivel, a qué frecuencia actúa, de acuerdo,
a qué frecuencia actúa, así es, porque ya veréis que hay algunos que constantemente dan,
bueno dan, nos queda en señal, constantemente su cumple las condiciones para pintar, de acuerdo,
sin más, esto es tan sencillo como si cumple pintas y no pues no pintas, vale, en este caso
en el mismo el case 1 pinta tanto el plot 1 como el plot 2, ¿verdad Alberto? exactamente, exactamente,
el hike, el plot 1, el plot 2, vale, vamos a verlo, sí, está poco como parece como al revés, ¿no?
Sí, sí, exactamente, sí, sí, está el filtro 1 es el log que es lo que os decía cierre diario por
encima de la media de cierres diarios que por efecto está 13, pero si le quieres cambiar el
valor pues lo cambias y cambia, de acuerdo, es decir, oye, pues a mí 13 me parece poco, yo le quiero
poner pues 50, de acuerdo, pues le pones 50 y automáticamente el show me, adiós, vale, el show me
pues cambia, veis, ya ha pintado, ya ha pintado distinto, vale, espera, que lo vamos a cambiar,
no Alberto, porque es como, es como contradituitivo, eh, esto al final simplemente, pues Alberto,
cuando lo ha probado, pues le ha puesto ese color, sin más, no tiene mayor historia, bueno, el que
estaba, le ha dejado el que estaba y ya se ha acabado, entonces ahora lo cambiamos y ya está,
lo cambiamos y ya está, vale, pero esto, como os digo, es, es, es importante para entender un
poco el, la idea, el setup y os lo recomiendo en general con todos los setups, de acuerdo, es decir,
verlos, mirar los setups en la pantalla, vale, mirar los setups, porque ahí verás cuando actúa o cuando
no, vale, bien, este era el uno, vale, este era el uno que, que era esto, repito, cierre mayor que la
media de 13 días y el máximo mayor que el máximo del día anterior, vale, este buen hombre pues había
hecho unos, unos, unos estudios aquí, por ello, vale, ¿cuál es el, cuál es el segundo? Este,
como os digo, es un posible filtro, este claramente es de Momentum, vale, este claramente es de
Momentum y si no recuerdo mal, poco efectivo, ¿verdad Alberto? Este es poco, poco efectivo, ¿de acuerdo?
Este era poco efectivo, como yo creo que ya sospechabais porque al final es muy poco restrictivo,
por sí solo, puede que a lo mejor en combinación con otro, ¿me entendéis? Es decir, es decir,
a lo mejor este, este para simplemente filtro de Momentum y luego una pauta de volatilidad,
pues a lo mejor ya funciona, ¿me entendéis? Pero por sí solo, pues es, es, es poca cosa, vale,
es poca cosa. Bien, ahora le ponemos el 2, el 2 es muy parecido, es muy, muy, muy parecido, lo único
que en vez de comparar, o sea, además del cierre por encima de la media, esto es igual, tiene el
Momentum, pero además la pauta de estos, si os fijáis, bueno, no iba a decir de velas,
en algunos casos son pautas de velas, pero es parecido al análisis candlesticks, a aquellos
que habéis hecho velas, ¿no? Y el cuerpo real, ¿de acuerdo? Todo este tipo de cosas, el candlestick
al final, cuerpo real es cierre menos open, open menos high, el rango es high menos low, ¿vale?
Es decir, todo este tipo de demande es muy visual, ¿de acuerdo? Es muy visual trabajar este tipo de
pautas, ¿vale? En este caso comparaba el high con el high, muy obvio, pero aquí lo que haces es
comparar el cierre con el open, ¿vale? Aquí comparar el cierre con el open, ¿qué haces comparando el cierre
con el open? Bueno, quiere decir que ha sido una vela alcista, no quiere decir que el día ha subido,
fijaros, porque el día si ha subido es cierre contra cierre anterior, vale, cierre contra open
es que la vela es alcista, ¿entendéis? Es decir, que durante la jornada ha subido desde que ha abierto,
pero ha podido abrir con un gap, ¿entendéis? Ha podido abrir con un gap, como por ejemplo hoy el
mercado ha abierto con un gap al alza, el mercado americano, pues y desde ahí puede caer y entonces
el cierre no sería mayor que el open, aunque la sesión sea alcista, ¿entendéis? Entonces esto al
final es una figura de velas, esto quiere decir que el cuerpo, el cuerpo de la vela es azul,
¿entendéis? No es que sepáis candlestick, ¿vale? Y entonces ya marca distinto, porque como tiene
que cumplir las dos, antes todo esto era igual, bueno no porque era de 50, hay cuidado, y ahora
pues aquí ya tiene algunos días donde esto no se da, vale, esto no se da también, vale, bueno,
es otro otro filtro, bien, entonces este es otro nuevamente, pues podemos, como os digo,
el show me viene muy muy muy bien para para verlo en el gráfico, vale, ¿qué más? El tercero,
ya vais a ver que algunos cambia un poco más, estos son bastante parecidos, al final tenemos
los de narro y demás, que son los que más utiliza la industria, aquí viene el 3, que nuevamente
es muy parecido, todos estos todos estos primeros mantienen el mismo criterio de cierre mayor que
lo que cambia es un poco la segunda pauta, vale, este es lo que os decía, es parecido al anterior,
porque el anterior es cierre mayor que open, y la mayoría de veces que pase esto va a pasar que
el cierre sea mayor que el cierre anterior, pero no siempre, entonces bueno, es ese matiz probar uno
contra otro, la cual es probar las diferencias, y luego también dependerá de qué activo, habrán
activos que cambie más más que otros, vale, pero bueno, este realmente es parecido, ¿ves? Aquí por
ejemplo, pues ya hay días más rojos, vamos al siguiente, porque esos son muy muy muy similares,
vale, el cuarto ya es más interesante y de esto lo veréis, es muy habitual, de acuerdo, y la primera
vez que lo ves es como raro, pero ya os lo explico y veréis que no está raro, es que no está raro,
eso ya cambia más, aquí ya la cosa ya no está tan clara, veis, ya hay días que sí, aquí sube,
sube, sube, en cambio no lo ha marcado, vale, no se le cumplía la condición, ¿qué condición es
esa? ¿Qué condición es esa? Seguimos que la media sea, en este caso esta se viene cumpliendo hace
días, es decir, esta no es el problema, la que está marcando un poco la diferencia es la segunda
parte, ¿no? Se tienen que cumplir las dos, vale, es que el open sea mayor, la voy a leer mejor en
el código está, que el open sea mayor que el low más una cantidad, más una cantidad, ¿de acuerdo?
No es simplemente el open contra el low, es que el open sea mayor que el low más una cantidad,
y esta cantidad es la mitad de la vela, la mitad del cuerpo de la vela, de todo el rango de la vela,
esto es muy habitual, lo veréis muchas veces con un 05, con la mitad y también a veces lo he visto
yo bastante en tercios, ¿de acuerdo? Es decir, al final, esto, ya digo, proviene bastante del
candlestick, esto hablaba bastante de ello, se llamaba el autor este que se hizo tan popular
de ni son ni son ni son de velas, vale, es decir, al final tú tienes una vela y una vela al final,
voy a intentar atreverme, voy a intentar atreverme, pero aquí ahora, es que hay una manera de compartir
que despeja la pantalla y dejaréis de ver este magnífico mamífero que es bonito, no os lo negaré,
pero ahora mismo hay el despejar conflicto, ¿cómo qué conflicto? A ver, espérate, dejo de compartir
y entonces lo hago, porque si no, no va a ir a despejar, ahora sí, vale, es que le pones despejar
y cuando sigas el escritorio te pones esta pizarra, esto pues viene bien, para un gran dibujante como yo,
viene muy bien, vale, tú al final de siempre estamos más acostumbrados a las velas, digamos,
yo que sé así, que no son velas, que son barras, vale, pero ya sabéis aquellos que no, que sé que
hay varios que lleváis poco tiempo, que estáis empezando, a ver, empiezo, al final hay las velas,
pero ¿y por qué no lo enseño en un gráfico, no? es que también soy idiota, es que es que de verdad,
es que de verdad hay veces que dices,
porque lo enseño en un gráfico, ya está, ¿no? es que es verdad, mira, vamos a ver un gráfico,
mira, ves que bien, pues eso son las velas, de acuerdo, al final dependiendo del color,
aquellos que no se suabilizados, es obvio, cuando es azul quiere decir que el cierre es mayor que
el open, cuando es roja quiere decir que el cierre es menor que el open, vale, la mechita es el máximo
y cuando no hay mechita como aquí, pues quiere decir que el mínimo es la apertura, esto creo
que para todo el mundo o para evidentemente la mayoría está muy claro, pues casi todas estas
figuras en el fondo vienen de esto, de acuerdo, de entender esto y de entender que esto, que es
verdad, que por sí solos tienen poco poder predictivo anualizadas solas, como complementos
de filtros son bastante útiles, porque al final esto te está hablando de la estructura del mercado
y por añadido de las fuerzas del mercado, de acuerdo, el mercado es oferta y demanda y al final
una vela por sí sola, sobre todo esos cinco minutos, pero evidentemente como siempre hay más ruido tal,
en diario, al final te está diciendo mucho sobre la estructura y quien controla el mercado, la vela
en sí, todo el rato, todo el rato hasta las más tontas y de hecho las más tontas usualmente son
las que más información y claro que no hay ciencias ciertas, pero fijaros que tras impulso
muchas veces hay velas con mechas, con cuerpos pequeños, lo veis, esto claramente está marcando
un rango lateral, es perfecto, es decir, yo tengo un tirón, espera que me voy a poner, más que ir
el texto voy a ir pintando yo, porque si no luego voy a tener que ir borrando y luego voy a abrir el
epic pen que me da mejor, luego ya voy borrando y ya está, es decir, tú por ejemplo tienes esta
vela que es un tirón fuerte y automáticamente luego que te viene, ves una cuerpa con un velito
de nada, un cuerpito de nada, mechita, mechita, que es lo más probable de esto, es lo más probable
es continuación, es así que lo más probable ya indica que no es seguro, pero es así, pues esto al
final es una estructura que a mí me hace, me puede hacer decir, yo puedo utilizarlo a lo mejor en
sistemas, si puedo medirlo de alguna manera, que es probable que la siguiente rotura sea fuerte,
¿por qué? porque las congestiones de precios provocan, son un anticipo de expansiones y esto
es siempre esta pauta que hay, que hay muchas veces que pues la contracción dura una teronidad y te
duermes, es decir, y esto pasa y aquí en toda esta estructura dices, mira pues aquí esta puede ser
buena y al final no lo ves y se va abajo, claro que hay fallos, pero ligando un poquito con lo
que decía antes de Sénén, antes del lado largo, ¿qué pasa en el lado largo? tú en el lado
en el lado largo, ¿por qué es más complicado? porque esto es muy aprovechable para un volatility
breakout, pero ves no marca tendencia, en cambio esto para un volatility breakout no es aprovechable,
esto es aprovechable para un tendencial, tenemos, eso es diario ahora, entonces es otro tipo de
sistema, yo para operar aquí iré mejor en tendencial, ¿puedo aprovechar el volatility
breakout del lado largo? sí que puedo, pero entiendes, es distinto, porque si puedo coger
esta vela y me salgo, pero luego ya está, aquí ya es complicado entrar muchas veces, en muchos casos
será complicado entrar, habrá muchos volatility breakout, de hecho el otro que tenemos preparado
os lo entregaré al final, si no os lo entrego el código hoy os lo subiremos mañana, pero ya os
enseñaré seguro, al final aquí no entra ya, no entra, porque su manera de identificar el breakout
requiere descanso, cuando ya está tendencia no es su partida, pues todo esto que al final son figuras
de velas, todas estas que os digo que vienen aquí que son el rango, una parte del rango, lo que hay
detrás al final es una vela, es una figura de vela, es decir, cuando yo estoy midiendo la mitad
del rango, esto si os cuesta, la mejor manera es pasarlo a números, un poco cuenta la vieja,
te coges unas cuantas velas y lo haces y te haces el cálculo, entonces lo entiendes, te haces el
cálculo de lo que está haciendo, porque así dices la mitad del rango más el low, como que
suena raro, pero vamos a intentar, vamos a intentar, a ver donde tengo ahora el código,
aquí no, vamos a intentar de esto que está aquí escrito, pintarlo, a ver si lo consigo yo pintar
en una vela, en una vela que haya, bueno, como lo tengo puesto, bueno, en cualquiera de estas,
claro, cualquiera de estas me está dando truco, lo cual está pintada, la alcista, esto lo pinta
para todo el día, como usa el daily, se lo pintamos arriba, pero en realidad usa datos de abajo,
se entiende esto, usa datos de abajo, porque esas son pautas que se han analizadas en el diario,
se han analizados en el diario, es decir, en esta sesión toda ella cumple, quiere decir que en la
anterior cumple, es decir, esta al cierre es la que desata la sesión, entonces voy a ver si aquí
abajo lo voy a hacer candel, stick, ah no, me lo he hecho arriba, venga, perfecto, perfecto, lo he hecho
arriba, pues entro aquí y me lo hago yo, aquí no me lo pone azul, este servidor no es culé Alberto,
qué pasa aquí, esto tiene que ser rojo y azul y grana, esto no se repita, bastante valestamos para
al menos bajarlos del barco, hay que apoyar ahí, bueno, esta es la vela, espérate que ya me acerco,
ahí llegamos, esta es la vela que aparte de ahí pinta, porque ese es el cierre, este es el close,
530 las velas salieron al cierre y ahí empieza a pintar, entonces cuál es la regla que dice Fran?
Bueno Alberto es un poco maderista, no os lo tengáis en cuenta, aquí habréis de todos,
aquí habréis de todos, un poco del todo, vayas, un poco del todo, bueno, lo que os decía,
la media es obvio que está por encima del 13, pero luego además tenemos la otra condición que es
que, os la enseño aquí para que la veáis, porque es que en el powerpoint está como que se ve muy
rara, porque pone la ola en esa minúscula y yo creo que casi no se entiende, vale, a ver si aquí
lo veis más fácil, la primera es obvia, la segunda es esta, es esta, de acuerdo, perdón,
si el data 2 es el daily, o sea, olvidaros del data 2 no aporta nada al entendimiento,
simplemente que es el gráfico de abajo que está en diario, es decir, el open es mayor que low más
la mitad del rango, el open tiene que ser mayor que low, a ver si lo pinto yo aquí, es decir,
que participa aquí, participa el open, participa el low y participa el range que es esto,
concretamente participa la mitad de esto, es decir, este trozo, bueno, este es igual,
se entiende, ¿no?, la mitad, vale, vale, la mitad, entonces la regla es tan fácil, porque aquí,
así yo creo que se entiende mejor, es que le tengo que añadir yo este valor, que esto al final,
esto es un precio, pues se calcula, podemos calcular, ¿no Alberto?, podemos calcular,
me lo voy a apuntando, me lo voy a apuntar, ¿cómo?, perdón, tenemos un low que es 1769,
tenemos un open que es 17000, esto es un low, a ver que lo he perdido, 17103,
esto es el open y tenemos un rango que es la resta entre el high y el low,
de acuerdo, siempre que veáis rango es high menos low, es exactamente lo mismo,
que es 17136 menos 17069, eso es el rango, vale, yo calculo eso, eso me da 67 y eso me dice que lo
multiplique por 05, que es lo mismo que dividirlo por 2, estamos de acuerdo, ¿no?, la mitad, que es
33,5, el 05 es 33,5 puntos, vale, y entonces a mí la regla para ser true, tiene que ser que
el open, o sea, le tengo que sumar esto al low, el low era 1769 más 33,5 y me da 17102,5,
el open era 17103, por medio punto es true, vale, medio punto, pero lo que quiero que entendáis
es lo que significa, ¿de acuerdo?, fijaros que esto a mí me está diciendo, a mí me está comparando,
espera que voy a borrar, lo que en el fondo estoy comparando es la apertura, lo que me está diciendo
es que la apertura está lejos del mínimo, se entiende un poco la idea, ¿por qué?, porque si el mínimo
estuviera más cerca, si el mínimo estuviera más cerca, sumado a la mitad del rango al mínimo,
superaría el open, entendéis un poco cómo juegan este tipo de figuras, porque veréis muchas así,
que tú la lees, que tú la lees, es joder, esto que es la mitad del low más el high, no sé qué,
hay muchas versiones de este tipo, en el fondo es muy recomendable que hagáis este ejercicio de
entenderlo, ¿entendéis?, cuando ya estén a consumirlo pues es igual, pero es muy muy
importante en el teleanonimico cuantitativo entender el porqué de las cosas, esto en la teoría os lo
decía mucho a partir de los indicadores, todo oye, ya nada es el MACD, el RSI, el stock, o sea,
hay que entender qué hace cada cosa y lo mismo esto, o sea, no caer en meter filtros y meter y
no saber ni qué metéis, ¿entendéis?, es decir, coger una lista de 50 que podéis encontrar por ahí
un montón y meterlos, ¿vale?, o ir metiendo varios, puedes probarlos pero entendiendo qué hacer,
¿vale?, entendiendo qué hacer, ¿vale?, bien, este es uno de ellos que pues da true en determinados
casos, ¿vale?, bueno, porque esto lo que está indicando es esto, ¿vale?, lo que os digo, al final,
al comparar, al comparar el open, a ver, estoy aquí arriba, aquí, al comparar, bueno, primero,
estoy en tendencia alcista, todos parten de eso, ¿vale?, estoy en tendencia alcista porque cierre
mayor que una media, ¿vale?, estoy en tendencia alcista, pero además de estar en tendencia alcista,
yo pido esto, luego veréis que hay otro que es con el close, o sea, no, no, ¿por qué el open? Bueno,
es porque hay varias, ¿vale?, hay varias, el open de a mentir la importancia, ahora me gusta más el
close, ¿vale?, perfecto, ahora en la siguiente lo vemos, ¿vale?, este es con el open, este lo que está
comparando es el open con el low, pero no directamente con el low, le suma la mitad del rank,
¿vale?, pero esto es una manera de decir que está lejos, ¿entendéis?, está lejos porque si,
si no estuviera lejos lo sobrepasea y de hecho no lo sobrepasa por medio punto, con relación,
o de hecho de otra manera, el open con relación al cuerpo, ¿vale?, el, el, el, bueno, no el cuerpo,
perdón, porque el cuerpo es esto, ¿vale?, todo el rango, el open está por encima de la mitad,
¿entendéis?, eso es un poco la otra manera de verlo, esto es como los balances de contabilidad,
puedes ver por el pasivo, por el activo, está, bueno, bien, esto, si fuera una línea recta,
se entiende, ¿no?, está por poco pero está por encima de la mitad, esto es lo que hace el
comparar, a comparar el open y ahora vamos a hacer lo mismo pero con el cierre, lo vamos a
cambiar, mirad, como está, esta también va a ser true, lo voy a mirar en esta misma, ¿vale?,
esperaros que lo voy a cambiar a la pauta, a ver si ahora le doy ahí al punto, muy bien,
edit y ahora le meto la 5, bueno, la del lado bajista, este es en azul, en rojo,
pues es lo contrario, es obvio, en vez de, sigue comparando el open, pero en vez del open con el
open con el high, restándole la mitad del rango, ¿vale?, esta, esta también es true con el 5,
que ya se ve que es, que es true, ¿vale?, borro, ¿vale?, y en el 5 ¿qué hace?, en el 5 es muy
parecido al anterior, seguimos comparando el, o sea, seguimos estando en tendencia al cista y un
cierre por encima de la media, que esto podría haber hecho separado, pero bueno, hemos respetado
al autor, tienes, pero, o sea, aquí hay dos filtros del uno, uno de momentum, cierre por encima de
la vera y además de pauta, ¿vale?, hay dos, momentum y pauta de precio, es súper habitual,
súper habitual este, este concepto de uno de momentum y otro, o sea, ¿por qué?, porque yo voy
a favor de tendencia, pero además de favor de tendencia quiero algo, ¿no?, y también puede
ser en contra de tendencia, cuidado, es decir, es muy habitual lo que os decía antes, que esto no
acertemisa, es decir, lo contrario, es decir, el cierre es menor que el cierre anterior, o sea,
yo estoy en tendencia al cista, pero el cierre es menor al anterior, es decir, estoy en una
corrección, sin llegar a perder la tendencia estoy en una corrección, esto también es muy muy
habitual, pero aquí de momento es tendencia y una figura de velas que vamos tratando de analizar
cada una, ¿no?, en este caso lo que os decía, lo que compara es el close con el low más el rango,
entonces nuevamente tenemos los mismos elementos, lo que pasa es que aquí ya no es el open,
sino el close, pero claro, aquí otra vez me está diciendo que lo que compara es el close sumándole
la mitad del rango, si le sumo la mitad del rango al close of data 2 mayor que el low más la mitad del
rango exactamente, es decir, yo al low nuevamente tengo el rango aquí, tengo el rango aquí y al
low le sumo la mitad, poco más o menos, así a ojo, es ahí ¿no? cuidado que estoy ya mejorando,
entonces yo al mínimo le sumo esta mitad y me quedo aquí donde estaba antes, lógicamente,
ahí me quedo en esta línea, el cierre es mayor que esta línea, por mucho más que antes, antes
era el open ya lo era por poco, pero ahora es mucho más, ¿entendéis un poco? entonces yo que estoy
comparando, estoy pidiéndole un cierre muy alejado del mínimo, ¿entendéis?, igual que antes el open,
es más estricta al open, es más estricta al open, el cierre es más fácil, podemos decirlo,
con el open es más estricta, pero entendéis un poco la diferencia de una y otra, una el open y
la otra, entonces esta vela es claramente, es decir, le estoy pidiendo una vela que sea muy alcista o
para ser ortodoxos, cierre muy, muy alejada del mínimo, eso es lo que le está pidiendo esta pauta,
y así ya vamos entrando un poco en esta mentalidad de entender las pautas, esto no solo se usa en
el revés, cuidado, este tipo de figuras os las estoy introduciendo aquí porque esto se utiliza
mucho, esto se utiliza mucho a nivel de filtros, a nivel de filtros, pero es muy típico en este
tipo de RV por lo que os decía, por aumentar la probabilidad de acierto, que a veces cuidado,
no siempre ganan más, esto, mira, vuelvo a referirme al sistema, porque lo has pasado,
se me olvidó comentarlo, que la leer tu email o lo he pensado, que tú lo comentabas, es que creo
que decías que no ganaba más, pero sí que aumenta la probabilidad, es que esto es muy habitual, es
muy habitual, y ahí en el sistema que ahora cuando llegue veréis que tiene siempre este dilema, es
decir, filtrar más o filtrar menos, ¿hasta dónde filtro?, ¿sabes?, es decir, porque filtro más,
aumento acierto, aumento profit factor, pero pierdo trade, gana menos, bueno, ahí está,
y no hay una, ya me anticipo a que alguien me lo pregunte, no hay una respuesta única, es decir,
pues hay que hacer esto y esto, no, depende de la cartera, depende de qué busque, ¿vale?,
entendéis, es decir, ahí está esta parte de, eso un día me lo comentaba un colega que además
está apuntado al curso, un amigo que decía, me decía esto, que si me está oyendo no se acordará,
me decía, o sea, yo, es que esto del teclado olímpico, pensaba que era como sota a caballo reino,
se sintió muy, muy, muy cuantitativo, único de colado, y estoy viendo que hay cierto grado de
inscripción, digo, bueno, hombre, cierto grado hay, pero es muy pequeño, está todo bastante
cerrado, pero sí, es verdad, al final hay cierto grado, hay cierto grado, y de hecho, si no lo hubiera,
si lo pensáis, si no lo hubiera, todo sería igual, todo el mundo ganaría o todo el mundo
perdería, no habría, no habría, no habría margen para que hubiera gente buena que te vala,
técnicamente hablando, no habría gente para que, no habría diferencias entre los resultados,
si todo fuera tan sota a caballo reino, tiene que haber algo distinto, entonces que tratamos de
protocolizarlo, tratamos de estandarizarlo, pero sí que hay cierto margen en algunas cosas,
sí que hay cierto margen en algunas cosas, porque al final siempre hay una persona detrás, eso es así,
eliminarlo al cien por cien es difícil, es difícil, aunque tratamos, tratamos de minimizarlo al máximo,
vale, si me estás en directo me saludas por ahí en el chat, que tú ya sabes quién eres y
me he ido, me he ido, me he ido aquí, vale, bueno, pues ya estaba mirado el 5, creo, ¿verdad?, el 5,
el 5, que era este que hemos visto el cierre, bueno, no hemos visto el lado negativo,
lo pongo un momentito aquí, simplemente para que lo veáis, pero vaya, que es un poco lo mismo,
un poco lo mismo, lo único, pues bueno, que en un mercado de cista cuesta más, porque recordad
que se tienen que dar las dos, el cierre tiene que ser inferior al cierre, a la media de cierres,
si esa ya no se da, ya da igual si se da la de velas, vale, entonces se tienen que dar las dos,
entonces aquí fijaros por ejemplo que se da, vale, ya lo veis, tiene que ser, ahora ya lo veis
intuitivamente, ya lo veis intuitivamente, tiene que ser una vela que cierre, vale, en este caso,
que cierre la parte baja del rango, eso es, perdón, no me sirves, no me quiero poner ahí,
no quiero invadir la vela, vale, al final es la mitad del rango, lo que al máximo le sumo la
mitad del rango, pero no me quedo más o menos ahí, pues esa raya tiene que estar por debajo del
cierre, por encima, lo está, o sea, el cierre tiene que ser menor, se entiende, esta con el open no
lo cumpliría, veis, porque el open está aquí arriba, esta con el open no estaría pintada roja,
la número 4 no estaría pintada, porque la mitad del rango cae por debajo del open, por el cierre
sí, lo veis, el cierre está debajo de esta línea, pero el open está por encima, entonces,
entendéis, que cómo van estas figuras, y lo que os digo, al final detrás hay un candlestick,
o sea, un candlestick no en el sentido estético, sino en el sentido técnico, pero la estética
ayuda mucho a entenderlo, el candlestick porque a gente le gusta, porque es visual, porque esto
por sí solo a mí me da mucha información, me estaba hablando de que hemos cerrado muy alejado
de la apertura, me acuerdo que hace una sesión de rango importante, que también hay bastante mecha
en los dos lados, que tiene una cierta indefinición, porque al final el precio ha vuelto bastante del
mínimo, ya nos digo esta, habrá indefinición absoluta, ha habido mucho rango, pero al final
ha cerrado donde ha abierto, entonces al final las velas te dan mucha mucha información, se utiliza
mucho en este tipo de cosas. Por las seis seguimos en este tipo, como son tres, es esta de aquí,
es la de abajo del todo, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, son tres, correctísimo, correctísimo, está mezclando ya,
está mezclando, está mezclando, porque fijaros que sigue introduciendo la media, pero ya compara
cierre con open, que esto ya lo habíamos hecho aquí, o sea es esta con algo más, lo veis no,
es esta con algo más, y que algo más, pues vamos a verlo, que el range, recordaros que es high menos low,
sea mayor del 1% de la media de 13 días, esto que nos está diciendo, que sea un rango amplio, es decir
que haya sido una vela volátil, esto es una manera de medir la volatilidad, entendéis no, es una manera de medir la
volatilidad, o sea está incorporando la volatilidad, porque recordaros que uno de los indicadores que
usamos para medir la volatilidad es el average true range, que es eso, es la media de los range,
entonces esto lo que hace es comparar el range, que es el range de una vela, el average true range es de
varias, pues esta es de una, tiene que ser mayor que el 1% de la media, de la media de 13, esto se lo
veis aquí en el código, este era el 6, ¿verdad Alberto?, lo que os digo, cierre mayor que open,
range of data 2 mayor que la media de cierres,
sí, bueno aquí hay que suponer que se refiere a la virgen de los clothes, claro,
es así, es así, porque si no no tenía sentido, no podría dar,
entonces este ya todavía es menos intuitivo, vamos a tratar de verlo, vamos a tratar de
de verlo en la pantalla los dos primeros son claros ya los hemos visto de hecho
ya los hemos visto ya veis que aquí ya pinta poco porque porque le estamos
pidiendo muchas cosas es un filtro son tres en realidad son tres pero bueno
vamos a ver este de aquí para para para de hecho este ya no se está pintando
todas porque esto quiere decir que no nos hemos referido todo el rato el data 2
alberto los mayor que a ver es close que falta el data 2 aquí me ves has
referido al data 1 en mitad a mitad a todo el rato se está refiriendo al data
2 entendemos no has visto no y si todos son iguales si todos todos si no dice
nada todo todo es cierre mar que habrá 13 si si esto esto todo el ver todo caso
si éste lo es el otro también es decir que no hay ningún motivo para que
pensar que no no da igual nada pero que te quiero decir que si éste es así
estos también o sea no hace ninguna mención al respecto por lo tanto no hay
ningún motivo para interpretar que utiliza un criterio distinto hay que
entender que sea el 1 o el 2 en todos es el mismo en todos es el mismo no yo estoy
que aseguro que siempre data más que data 2 se refiere al a diario el hecho
de que sea data 2 porque nosotros tenemos el diario en el data 2 pues por
él el diario del data 1 y hacerlo con el data 1 entonces al final es porque él
lo tiene lo tiene el diario del data 2 entonces es data 2 seguro es data 2
seguro entonces por eso te lo pintaba te lo pintaba de cientos igual lo he dicho
que no no que no lo veo no lo voy a cambiar a ver no lo voy a ver entonces
rompo los restos el 7 va con el data 2 alberto pero el mismo indicador sirve
para todos y ahora el 7 para con data 2 entonces que hago cambio todo el rato
data 1 data 2 me entiendes o que te voy a decir o sea éste éste es tan a dos es
sólo el 6 que está en el data es sólo el 6 que está es sólo el 6 es sólo el 6
por eso te digo si al final lo cambio en ese me voy a pasar me voy a liar no
pasa nada es el único es el único no no no no sólo ese sólo ese sólo ese sólo
es está en el data en el data 1 y además sólo la primera parte la segunda
está bien se está olvidado sin más ahora un par de meses de sueldo
suspendido y ya está esto se arregla rápido sino que el bar se ha ganado la
champions y ya está tío y yo creo que con eso yo me daría por pagado y con
eso me daría por por pagado a champions penalti injusto a poder ser en el último
minuto y ya está vamos vale esto aquí es data 2 le damos a ff 3 y creo que no
me ha dejado ninguno más vale esto porque me he dado cuenta pues no ah bueno
es que estoy en el dedicado claro y lo tengo abierto en el mío para que no
tengo que lo tengo abierto en el mío a ver si si si si lo tengo abierto en el
mío lo editaba en el mío y estoy en el dedicado aquí es igual es igual abierto
que voy a tener que mover una pantalla la otra
arriba abajo así gracias ahí tienes razón vamos ya estaba no más eso es no
vuelvo aquí para cierro de un lío aquí el lenguaje es de esta hora no sí vale
ahora ya las pinta todas eso me da la pista porque al no pintarlas todas quiere
decir que se está refiriendo a la regla de ese gráfico porque si tú te estás
refiriendo al data al data 2 la regla sólo se evalúa en esta vela y por lo
tanto todas las de sería van pintadas no puede haber ninguna que no entonces por
eso me ha dado la pista de que había alguna de la que estaba mirando al otro
al final se cumple igual porque esa era la menos restrictiva os acordáis era la
menos en la menos restrictiva era la primera la de la media entonces si se
cumplía arriba se cumplía abajo probablemente y eso sí vale bien entonces
vamos a tratar de entender esta esta otra pauta para lo que me voy a poner ya
desde aquí estamos en las seis no seis vale recordamos las dos primeras vale
las dos primeras era como ésta era cierre en tendencia y cierre mayor que
open es decir velita verde vale velita verde bastante claro lo que le añade
ésta es este componente de volatilidad vale que cómo lo cómo lo hace lo que
hace es comparar el range nuevamente nuevamente vuelve a meter el range
esperamos el range acordaros que es todo esto toda esta medida es el range hay
menos low y lo que nos está diciendo es que el range tiene que ser mayor que la
media de los cierres cuáles la media de los cierres es esta línea la media de
los cierres es esta línea azul esto es justamente la media de los cierres vale
nos dice que tiene que ser concretamente concretamente concretamente concretamente
a ver que no lo veo ahora el 6 data de open range mayor que la media por 0 1 es
decir por un 1% es un poco raro esto al final multiplica esto por 0 1 o sea la
media de cierres es esta línea alberto ya es como raro la ver 17.022 por 0 0 1 me
da 170 puntos 170 puntos y el rango éste pues es mayor tiene que ser mayor a
170 puntos vale vale claro claro bueno nuevamente nos está que nos está
diciendo que es una vela de muchísimo rango entendéis es una manera una
manera de mirar es decir una vela muy volátil este yo le veo bastante sentido
no sé al final creo que el 6 no era de los mejores y es parecido el 7 si esto
le veo sentido porque está está acordaros que os hablé de os hablé de
las pautas os hablé de momento os hablé de volatilidad contracción expansión
contracción expansión vale la volatilidad la volatilidad casi siempre
participa en este tipo de sistemas digo casi por ser prudente porque porque
que hay más para definir el rango lo que os digo de la estructura no estructura
que es tendencia de volatilidad esos dos vectores son básicos y al final es lo
que me casi mejor define a un mercado es tendencia volatilidad tendencia os la
está metiendo todo el rato en la primera vale todo el rato en la primera
espera que borro todo el rato en la primera os la está metiendo cierre
mayor que a ver luego una de velas aquí te sigue manteniendo una de velas que la
verdad la de cierre mayor que open puede haber algún caso que ahora se me escape
pero la veo totalmente rebundante porque si el range es mayor a no bueno es el
range vale no podría ser bajista claro claro podría tener ese rango enorme ser
bajista claro claro claro sí sí sí lo que quiere es tendencia al cista que la
vela sea verde y de muchísimo rango eso eso identifica este y a lo mejor podría
ir mejor que podría ir mejor en el contrario es decir yo este que creo que
no está probado aquí porque el 7 es distinto si efectivamente el 7 es eso es
y el 7 es el que va bien es que es que pensaba que no era ser 7 el 7 que va
bien es que esto en el otro sistema lo hacemos así es lo que os digo ves que
pide el 7 vamos ya al 7 que queda claro si alguien no me sigue que me diga el
7 pide que el cierre sea menor es decir que la tendencia sea al cista haya
volatilidad pero que el día ya ha sido bajista el día ya ha sido bajista esa
le gusta para el cista y a mí también me gusta y a mi también me gusta
esta es el 7 aquí no va a dar true a dar tú a mejor en la siguiente tampoco
tampoco da true en la siguiente bueno puede ser que sea porque no le da el
rango eso que os digo claro es no le da rango tiene que tiene que cumplir la
rango es muy estricta a ver déjame ver el código que esté que esté correcto
close of data 2 mayor que el average el close of data 2 correctísimo close of
data 2 menor que el open of data 2 correctísimo y range of data 2 mayor
que el average el close of data 2 por el 001 es correcto es correcto que se le
pague se le pague el bingo es correcto claro es complicado porque es
complicado porque como le está pidiendo tendencia al cista además es de 13
días tampoco es de muchos días mucha volatilidad que acordaros que la
volatilidad es bajista vale y encima que haya cortado entonces al final le está
le está costando ves aquí la da por los pelos la da por los pelos esta nada
cómoda porque cierra por encima es tiene mucho rango es bajista y la cierra
la da y la marca toda y aquí lo mismo aún se aguanta y aquí ya se va a
invertir es aquí ya se va a invertir y había una roja cercana me ha parecido
ver aquí está es para para y está la contraria ves vela ya está por debajo de
la media ya está por debajo de la media la vela es verde de acuerdo y mucho rango
es decir esta es muy muy interesante vale puede ser que no está bien puesta
pero bueno pero lo que me da mucho aquí en esa cambiaba ves por eso porque sí
que me da ya me había dado cuenta que no porque se está por debajo alberto y
está pintada roja y lo que algo pasa a media está mal puesta pero bueno cambia
poco en las que hemos visto pues no cambiaba entonces ahí está ahí está
bueno pues todas estas que no las vamos a repasar todas ya os digo que este
código ya os lo haremos llegar vale ya os lo haremos llegar que son estos
códigos esto de hecho reglas hecho filtros esto con un show me se pinta
vale además de estas como veis ya digo ahí hay hay otras en el no aquí hay
otras o sea que hay siete pero que en el indicador que ha hecho alberto en el
show me hay hay más vale porque están los narro reyes y todas estas que ya
habíamos comentado vale vamos a verlas para que esas ya nos las puedo enseñar
ahí porque ahí está hasta las siete vale la 8 es un narro reyes si os abre la
función veis que es un narro reyes un arro reyes de n pelas en este caso creo
que está definido para para cuatro pero es para siete vale digamos que tú le
pasas el input que le que le defines vale pero es con un bucle for está hecho
una función no no no entramos en tecnicismo por favor da igual vale da
igual esto es como técnicamente le ha hecho le ha hecho alberto pero no no
tiene mayor importancia de acuerdo simplemente es que durante un número de
velas que puede que en este caso son cuatro se cumple una determinada
condición que es que el rango de la siguiente sea menor era así alberto no
en las anteriores exactamente eso es eso es que durante las cuatro tiene que dar
truco exactamente tiene que dar truco se tiene que ser mantenerse el rango menor
vale es sólo que en alguna no se dé pues ya no ya no ya no será o sea ya es
false ya es false esto puede ser para cuatro puede ser para siete esto el
primero que bueno yo diría que es el primero luego ha habido muchos autores
pero craven lo explicaba en esta serie de artículos que os pasamos es
correcto pero no lo pasamos así y pero ya digo se usa se usa usa bastante este
el 8 si si si exactamente usaba los mismos artículos que usaba la media de
los de los narrows es un poco raro si está bueno claro dependiendo de cuántas
velas 4 7 y porque pinta doble ahí ah vale te he dido te he dido te he dido si
si porque desde el filtro de detección pero aquí ahora podrías añadirle el
filtro de detección es decir exacto este es sólo el narro pero puedes meterle
además tener cien arroba tienes como os decía antes es bastante habitual es
bastante habitual incorporar el momento siempre es bastante habitual incorporar
el momento entonces aquí tienes el urb el urb el 8 es lo que os decía para aquí
simplemente es que se cumple el narro de 4 que que se cumple en esta pues lo que
os digo quiere decir que el rango voy a ver así para que lo veáis se cumple en
quiere decir que en todas ellas o sea que en esta vela todas las cuatro
anteriores tienen un rango mayor a esta se entiende no todas ellas sólo que una
no tuviera vale la vela la vela que da que desencadena el narro pues está
porque porque está está como esta esta esta esta o sea que esta correlación a
anteriores tiene el rango inferior ese es un poco narro de 4 si es de 7 pues
pasa en 7 esta era la regla 8 la regla 9 de hecho es que es de 7 la regla es la
8 la 9 es un narro de 7 y ahí creo que no se va a cumplir efectivamente pero un
poquito más adelante si es claro es más difícil lógicamente pero es que no
fijaros que esto no esto es pauta se narro a veces gente que la confunde con
los insight de acuerdo es decir el narro es una pauta de volatilidad o mejor
dicho es la mejor pauta que hay de contracción tendéis cuando hablaba
contracción de expansión y por eso la usa como ejemplo vale porque porque un
narro de 4 quiere decir que el mercado está comprimido es aquello que veis el
mercado está perdiendo aunque tenga direccionalidad luego yo puedo también
direccionalidad y usarlo si quiero pero quiere decir que el mercado está
perdiendo volatilidad y qué pasa que se anticipa expansión fijaros que las ve
las siguientes son de buen rango lo veis es así casualmente y eso es bastante
habitual cuando un mercado tú tienes un narro 7 lo normal es que las ve las
siguientes sean de expansión no el cien por cien de las veces pero ver es que es
bastante habitual vale pero es que es bastante habitual
carlos aquí está las siguientes muy vera fuerte es bastante bastante habitual
esta no por ejemplo está no se cumple tarda un poco vale pero es bastante
habitual el narro es una pauta de rango de volatilidad no es lo mismo como
insight que también es una pauta de volatilidad pero que se quiere decir que
la vela está contenida dentro del anterior es como una especie de
envolvente no pero al revés o sea bueno estas en las narro 4 la narro 7 lo está
la narro con tendencia y varias paredes el 12 por ejemplo el 11
es igual no estas son iguales todas el 8 8 9 4 7 la 10 la 10 es igual alberto a la
8 no no narro perdón es no narro esta la 10 niega el narro de 4 al revés se
va a cumplir mucho y cuando no es un narro de 4 la 11 es cuando no es un
narro de 7 a veces va a cumplir mucho todavía más se va a cumplir porque hay
pocos narros de 7 por lo tanto cuando es 7 es la mayoría del tiempo y luego a
partir de la 12 es ya mezcla tendencia de acuerdo la 12 esto ya os lo pasaré
si esto nos lo voy enseñando todo porque si no nos quedamos aquí clavados toda la
clase que ya casi estamos haciéndolo pero pero quiero pasar un poco al código
vale al sistema en sí está esta ya es un poco a mí me gusta más es decir es
narro de 4 vale narro de 4 pero
cierre mayor que la media de acuerdo tendencia también tendencia es decir tienes que tener
una ruta entonces ahí yo voy para el largo yo voy para el largo puede funcionar puede no funcionar
pero está en principio es buena es buena es buena sé que las buenas fueron a cuatro las
bueno las buenas las mejores en el dax por ejemplo fueron la 4 la 7 la 4 la 7 pero esto
puede cambiar mucho por el activo y además a estas mismas que ya los voy a pasar todas
jugar con ellas por con ellas combinarlas analizar hacerlas hacer vuestras al final
con todo esto que os hemos pasado prácticamente todas las de no están todas pero son derivadas
de ellas ya es el concepto es el concepto no están todas porque es que todas es imposible
es que no se acaba nunca todas pero pero ahí están en total en este en estos son mis ahí 19 19 19
pautas vale 19 pautas que son las que luego podéis usar igual para los sistemas lo mismo
igual que aquí es un case para pintar luego la puedes usar para la para la estrategia que
os la enseño está hasta la 18 gobeys soldado y la 19 vuelve a meter en la tendencia y luego
pidas pide otra vez el rango es el rango sólo el rango quitando figura de velas es muy para
es esta es esta de aquí pero quitando cierre mayor que open o cierre menor que open vale es
sólo tenencia al cista es decir cierre mayor que la media de 13 cierres y el range mayor que
el 1% de la media de los cierres estas dos estas la 19 bueno y ese es el código 4 que
este tenemos el huerta y para no no lo hago en un momento lo hago en un momento este es un poco
el paper del 4 que al final lógicamente es parecido a los otros que habíais que habíais
visto simplemente pues es un poquito una revisión de los de los conceptos un poco una una una
colocación un poquito más más limpia de todo los filtros que los hacemos con switch con cases
luego hay salidas posibles por trailing salidas posibles con atr o sin atr por esto por profit
es un poco todo desarrollado lo que habíais visto hasta ahora money management general vale y aquí
está explicado vale está explicado sólo código para que podáis adaptarlo si es necesario otro
código a otro lenguaje perdón y y luego como no pues está el código de está el código de easy
language y ahí está metido todo ahora os lo enseño dentro del easy language que se lee mejor
que aquí se le mejor que aquí pero ahora os lo os lo paso os lo enseño aquí que es este vale es
el mismo el mismo concepto recordar que hay que usar dos datas y ahora vamos al gráfico hemos
incorporado también una variable que os decía que es uso atr que es simplemente para si quiero
los stocks por usar un múltiplo de atr o usar un porcentaje vale es decir estos tres variables el
multiplicador o bien multiplicar el precio y multiplicar la tierra dependiendo si esto es
false o estru como bien explica aquí y poco más además ya lo habíais visto es verdad que en este
código hemos desarrollado un poquito más el tema de la hora de inicio ya se calcula vale esto
nuevamente es técnico el que lo entienda pues bien el que no que no se maré de verdad no de la otra
manera también lo pones a manija ya está aquí simplemente tú controlas el inicio y es un código
que permite optimizar el tiempo vale está un poco un poco avanzado estos sitios voy a dar una
pequeña explicación para que quede grabado de verdad ahora el que el que ahora se me pierda yo
lo voy a explicar pero que revise la grabación vale porque porque si no vamos a estar siete horas
con ello porque entiendo que puede ser un poco complejo mira ya abierto alberto lento pero seguro
lento pero seguro lento pero seguro vale el que abro aquí era el de el de ppc 2 verdad aberto
ppc 2 a ver si va a ser más rápido ahora porque en principio también lo tenía abierto aquí ya
lo voy a cerrar porque el día mucho los tallas para mirar mientras voy a hacer el voy a hacer el
power point vale ahí perdón el pdf porque este el pdf creado no sé por qué lo tengo solo al
cual a los revés 0 4 vale vale espero espero el de los filtros sí que estaba verdad es esta parte
y este el filtro os lo paso ahora el paper también y los easy language a ver los podíamos meter
a ver si lo podemos ahora cuando acabes compíralo el uno para compartir el easy language vale porque
se lo pondré ahí también el lo exportado que solo tenga esos dos o sea bueno esos dos el rb este
también el mío también etcétera los tres códigos vale ahora estos lo es así que lo puedo hacer pdf
no de los filtros solo este luego sin seguridad que se lo puedan copiar bien determinado
pero esto lo tenía aquí en prácticas tenía una cosa material para alumnos
aquí porque así que los filtros aquí va porque no se me guarda nunca este ahora ahora lo pondré
todo ahí y luego ya mañana si no lo subo también a esta media colocada de verdad
me voy a quitar la cámara por si acaso porque el final tampoco aporta mucho y encima no se graba
al final de preguntas vamos bien no si está bien está medio está medio tonto bueno se ha vuelto
arriba esto ha vuelto arriba esto es bien es bien es bien esto esto es bien acabamos buen mes estamos
15 en argüinia bueno estamos ahí bien con los dos queda que dame sound por eso que no resucita
bueno pues nada puedo hacer el otro pdf alberto no más que nada porque por a ver si de mientras
vuelve porque está el trasección tratando de cargar el wasp es nada nada seguro que no
seguro que no a ver el otro word a ver si mientras hago el pdf el el este vuelve hoy
me salta la pausa ya casi que no lo hacemos en chicos que además juega el barça y a ver si
puedo llegar a ver que sea la segunda parte ya para la hora que es no lo hago vale pues ya lo
tengo no sé si alberto exportado eso me lo voy a exportar yo porque aquí había hecho este
cambio con lo cual ya estaba bien se ha compilado ese es el antiguo es el antiguo 2 para el otro
el otro el otro el show me quista para este estaba bien no me la voy a exportar así os
meto también aquí porque igual en el disco luego me da problemas y a menos ya los que
estáis aquí os lo lleváis sabes porque el disco parece que dijo un día no me acuerdo
que quién era que no podía subir código pero bueno por si acaso este este y este es lo que
vamos a tratar hoy voy a meter aquí en prácticas manera para alumnos o el revés 12 de marzo vale
12 de marzo venga sergi ánimo igual un día de estos aprendes a escribir y hoy nos damos
nos llevamos todos una alegría de marzo ya exportar el código alberto de estos tres ya exportar el
código de estos tres de vale os pongo os pongo el material ahí vale os pongo el material ahí de
esos de esos tres a los dos pdf es y el código easy language tanto multicharts como es el
importar si lo tenéis multicharts a ver lo podéis importar directamente porque así es más más
cómodo el que ya tenga tres sesión directamente lo importa el que no pues lo convierte con el
cero de código carga un archivo a la vez bueno pues ya voy venga uno el primero ahí va el segundo
a ver el código si nos el archivo es informado no compatible perfecto pues no se puede que me
obliga aquí gif jpg doc y no no sí tampoco no lo puedo no lo puedo encapsular así que ya lo
subiré al al disco ahora lo subo lo subo el disco espero que me deje a mí lo que me deje vale de
momento tenéis los dos los dos pdf porque no me deja subir el disco vale bueno entonces seguimos
hablando del código que se estaba comentando acaba de cargar esto ya cargado ya cargado ok
ok lo que os decía estamos comentando las distintas impos no que ya lo habéis visto
ahí la elección filtro que no es más que los filtros que habéis visto no sé si ya en esta
versión están todos pues hay varios comentados porque los hemos ido probando y por un tema de
manía limpieza vale pues hay varios comentados ya sólo se ha quedado el que era el 4 y el que
era el 7 es el que era el 4 condición 4 condición 5 que era el 7 porque hemos ido haciendo distintas
pruebas y al final nos hemos quedado con estas vale pero insisto al final podéis vosotros
experimentar no sólo podéis sino que debéis experimentar vale al final está la parte del
canal el canal aquí sí que hay una variación en el sentido que si quiero usar la tierra o no
también está arriba comentado para añadirle algo más al canal podéis investigar con las
horas que es lo que ahora iba a explicaros vale lo que ahora iba a explicaros pero en ese no puedo
tengo uno cargado donde puede hacerlo alberto no tengo que abrir el del tiempo para el rango
no tengo abierto ahí no el dedicado pues mira lo voy a abrir es igual si ya se ha visto 70 veces
la IP verá y la tienes otra vez venga por mundo ahí no se ve nada por el conflicto vale perfecto
venga pues vamos conflicto compartir pantalla 4 es fijar que ahora ahora no aquí simplemente
porque esta es una cosa que hemos que hemos hecho que hemos hecho hoy vale lo hemos previamente
para aquellos que ya tengáis una de programación que irá a abordar lo que lo podéis abordar pero
insisto no es en absoluto obligatorio está el 2 está el 4 son a finales similares pequeñas
evoluciones el 4 lo que os digo sobre todo plantea esta mejora es optimizable vale tú marcas una hora
de inicio y una hora de final habéis visto aquí como inputs como ya se hacía anteriormente y esto
aquí en el código pues se utiliza vale ahora inicio aquí se utiliza para en el caso que lo desees
lógicamente podrás optimizar optimizar esas dos variables vale para ello tienes que tocar o
dicho mejor dicho la variable que se optimiza es minutos optimización aquí un comentario
verá estado de puta madre de puta madre que un comentario el verto vale esta es la variable que
sé que se optimiza como se optimiza bueno si tú le cargas la vela si tú lo tienes aquí por ejemplo
10 minutos vale pues al final cuando lo optimizas repito eso se queda grabado ese es el inicio que
le marcas vale y el incremento es decir el y eso es lo que él irá incrementando a la hora inicial
de acuerdo es decir que irá incrementando de 10 a 240 pues si es 9 pues 9 10 9 20 9 30 40 9 50 10
vale es decir este es el cálculo que el sistema ahora tiene en cuenta principios y no hay ningún
bag funcionará bien vale porque vale esto hay que hacerlo así porque ahora se enseña una opti
porque hay hay funciones esto es un poquito complejo de programación vale en el máster y
por ejemplo creo que hacemos alguna cosa de estas pero esto es hay que convertirlo de minus
su time con tanto menos hay dos palabras dos funciones que se encargaron poco de esto aquellos
que estéis aprendiendo y language que tengáis el manual aunque resulte complicado recordar vale
podéis ver las funciones y en la definición se le da eso se abre la ayuda y está bastante explicado
vale está explicado y te explica cómo se usa y demás vale y también la podéis incluso abrir y
ver vale cómo lo calcula que hace y demás si queréis verlo vale pero esto al final son
funciones necesarias para trabajar con tiempo porque no es un número al uso y entonces hay
que manipularlo para que no para que tenga sentido de acuerdo entonces hay que este código está
preparado para hacer esa manipulación y por lo tanto poder modificar si se desea insisto las
horas de inicio o de final vale en el caso que no pues se deja y punto vale el rango no
hace falta porque se calcula el rango se calcula es decir se calcula con el minutos hemos eliminado
espera que me había muteado barras rango a vale porque lo calcula desde la apertura entendido
entendido entendido si tú ahora si le cargas desde las 8 y es 9 30 y es en 30 minutos serán
tres barras al final él ya ya sabe cuando abre el mercado ya lo calcula el vale lo calcula por
eso está impuesto es necesario es necesario simplemente utiliza la que se podría usar el
día anterior este no estaría preparado para ello hay que cambiarlo pero simplemente pues lo
hemos hecho así porque queríamos que lo vierais vale y traducir esta esta variable si se quiere
usar el día anterior pues se cambia el código al final todo se puede todo se puede modificar
pero se está pensado para que calcula el rango desde que el mercado abra hasta la hora que yo
le diga y como decía es optimizable a través de la variable minutos optimización hemos hecho alguna
pequeño estudio por aquí este por ejemplo alberto creo que ha estado traseando con él un poco y
aquí pues hay una optimización de minutos de tiempo cambiando la barra está esto al final aquí
claro evidentemente cuando ves el dato si te lo quieres llevar a excel pues tendrás que hacer
una conversión en excel para si quieres que en vez de poner 90 pues ponga 9 más 90 no debe ser en
este caso que sería hora y media 90 minutos es una hora y media de acuerdo pues le añade eso esto le
añade hora y media la hora inicial al input inicial se le añade 100 minutos se le añade dos
horas al final funciona funciona así vale en cuanto a esto en cuanto a esto nada más el que
el código bueno en el dax en el dax habíamos obtenido este creo que está cargado con la
optilla bueno no este no estaba mal del todo si no recuerdo mal alberto pero porque es que no no
me no me va a bajar esto ahí es mil se va desde 6 7 6 millones bueno este este es bastante bien
es bastante bien es bastante bien que me gusta bastante aquí aquí rápidamente sin trabajar
en el excel muchas veces ya que haces vas ordenando por un ordenado por otro y buscas aquel en que
equilibra un poco vale que hay las funciones para hacer pruebas lógicamente el excel de que hacer
las más pero es para que veáis ahora un poco vale este es este gráfico para bastante poco pero bueno
es una cosa que entra dentro de lo decente nuevamente nuevamente entra en el territorio
lo que decíamos hablándose antes cuando hablamos con sene el lado corto es ahora lo vais a ver en
el otro que os voy a enseñar también quieren más mejores resultados no es extraño no no es revés
que le obligas a cerrar a fin de día no lo olvidéis vale no lo olvidéis esta es una
restricción que paga más el lado largo de hecho el lado corto no la paga nada el lado largo la
paga bastante entonces si un camino que tiene sene en el lado largo es dejarlo correr tratar
de dejarlo correr a lo mejor no siempre lo que te decía antes finalmente pero dejarlo no necesariamente
ir a no a quedarte al día siempre o al menos no siempre vale en algunos casos casos de alta
probabilidad lo que te decía por combinación de días por combinación de pauta vale pues que tenga
una especial seguridad imagínate ahora me lo invento imagínate que el narro 7 es especialmente
fiable pues cuando haya un 7 lo dejas dos cosas cosas de este tipo o por el día vale es decir
el largo va a salir ganando de quedarse el largo va a salir ganando mucho de quedarse el corto no
necesariamente a los que tenemos mil trades esto tiene comisiones vale esto tiene comisiones y
tiene mil mil operaciones vale y creo que todavía está a ver con qué estaba esto alberto esto está
con 930 tres barras de rango en 10 minutos decir un rango muy estrechito muy poco tal en el high en
el low esto puede mejorarse de acuerdo probar el typical price o incluso por ejemplo el modelo que
tenía robert hacho este no es malo es decir el mayor entre el open y el close y también probar
el typical price vale el high el low el high el low es el más intuitivo y está bien no es no está
mal no está mal en muchos activos va a ir bien pero es verdad que en activos muy volátiles a veces
te va a hacer ir muy tarde porque estás ya marcando tú buscas expansiones y elegir el high en el fondo
implica elegir una expansión cuando tú en el fondo estás diciéndome no puedes pensar que lo
bueno es que haya contracción antes de la expansión coño entonces no me anclas al high que es el límite
entendéis un poco la idea entonces se puede jugar incluso se puede tratar pero ya es un cambio
bastante importante de concepto no es un rb al uso no es un rb al uso pero porque queda distinto
decir hacer como bandas de medias y hacer canales pero no necesariamente que vengan definidos por
el máximo máximo si no puedes poner la media de los máximos algo así vale pero ya no es uno
revés muchas veces te va a caer por encima y ahí a lo mejor puedes comprar incluso limitada en la
vuelta distintas versiones vale pero el high el low es bastante restrictivo y y en muchas
veces hace ir tarde hacer tarde porque parte del rango ya está consumido dentro del mismo rango
entonces es un poco la la cosa aquí el filtro era el 4 vale el que estaba aportando más valor
acordaros que era era era este era el que habíamos el del open era menos resistivo que el del close
era el del open no perdón era más resistivo que el del close también el 7 habíamos obtenido buenos
resultados y hay varias combinaciones aquí hay un jugar con el tp y con el stop cambia mucho el
sistema vale pero este estas versiones con estos filtros ya hay ya hay versiones bastante
aprovechables o decentes tanto en dax como en sp pero lo creo que era bastante más complicado
porque en el petróleo había que hacer que aún no hemos hecho y ya no para el curso no lo vamos a
hacer por no seguir pero aquí sí que sería bastante interesante ahora que hemos implementado
esto del código trabajar antes por ejemplo que se ha cambiado el código lo explicaba que había
hecho este procedimiento y es como hay que hacerlo estas tres partes que os he dicho recordar no
primero setup clásico de entrada esto que engloba y es como hay que trabajarlo esto engloba está
esta parte vale esta parte es decir la hora el rango si uso el high el low si uso filtro de
ponerle un ranguito a la entrada eso es vale eso es la entrada ahí con las horas en el petróleo
hay mucho trabajo que hacer porque todos los futuros que tienen globex no pensar que tenéis
que ir a su sesión vale hay que buscar hay que buscar la sesión entonces ahí hay un primer trabajo
de buscar eso con este código podéis hacerlo podéis investigar cargar un histórico empezando
en una hora cargando en otro y a partir de ahí tratar de buscar un poco una optimización genérica
con algún con algún filtro que ya veáis que haya medio funcionado y no tocar nada es el sencillo
ir comparando unos a ver qué rango puedo ver que hay alguna más contracciones expansiones recordar
me interesan contracciones expansiones expansiones pero un poquito analizar esos
gráficos os puede ver muy bien también el código este del show me para verlo porque
es muy visual no verlo y ver a ver si podemos ver sesiones ver que hay suele tener pautas de
comportamiento a unas horas recordar por ejemplo las noticias tienen mucho que decir eso a qué
hora dan los inventarios de petróleo venga pues ahí hay volatilidad vale ahí hay volatilidad mejor
un rango antes de esa hora se puede montar lo mismo aplica las acciones a mejor puedes
coger en vez de ir a un open range breakout en el spy como como había hecho zenen o nosotros en
el futuro con el horario regular a lo mejor te puedes trabajar cargar todo el continuo o sea todo
el globex pero yo lo voy a trabajar de rango de 1 a 2 porque seca las dos salen las dos y
media salen las noticias se cae de volatilidad y voy a buscar eso voy a buscar esas expansiones
ahí no bueno pues se puede buscar las sesiones vale no hace falta ir a la sesión que marca
el mercado obligatoriamente entonces sobre todo sobre todo los que tienen globex aplica esto los
que ya tienen un horario más común pues ahí es lo que hay no pero petróleo o como os digo el
nasa que se ve que tienen 23 horas de mercado oro dentro de una sesión hay muchas sesiones
hay muchas sesiones y no tenéis por qué ir siempre a la misma vale entonces primero trabajar
las sesiones una vez he trabajado las sesiones trabajo los filtros una vez trabajado los filtros
trabajo stops tps etcétera vale ese es un poco el mecanismo ahora ya os pondré los códigos y
este lo vamos a hacer así de pasada para ya cerrar este este tema vale este está basado en
este mismo artículo él al final explica un un esto creo que no lo tengo preparado pero ya
intentaré a no ya lo enviamos este alberto no este no vale seguro que no en el material que
subimos el último día que subimos a ver sólo los de krabbel a todos estos rebetas era los de
krabbel sólo pues yo pensaba que eran esos vale bueno luego lo miramos de poner también vale
entonces este ya lo ya lo miraríamos de poner las las reglas pero es es porque no de este no
tenemos hecho un el paper porque lo he trabajado hoy es para el he trabajado hoy y nos ha dado
tiempo de acabar a hacer el paper todo esto vale entonces este es unas reglas muy sencillas que
son estas de aquí es un break out al uso vale esto es un poco mal en el lenguaje porque es
antiguo pero bueno es parecido y al final es fijaros cierre mayor que cierre anterior menor
que cierre anterior y cierre mayor que la media vale y la regla de compra es una regla que lleva
implícito una expansión vale lleva implícito una una expansión este lo he trabajado un poquito yo
hoy y le he añadido algunas cosas os lo he incluido en el easylanguage que ahora voy a subir al
disco si me deja es lo incluido este código es lo incluido vale no he optimizado nada más que los
filtros he dejado por defecto el setup de entrada vale pero sí que he estado trabajando en los
filtros el recomendaba usar bueno recomendaba decía que había muchos más pero que había probado un
par uno era la de x y el aterre los dos los he modificado un poco porque la de x en sí esto
no sé si lo sabéis pero si no yo os lo explico ahora mismo vale el adx es un indicador compuesto
que yo tengo aquí vale el adx es la línea que veis abajo marrón en la mayoría de plataformas
también aquí lo podéis meter solo yo los lo voy a meter vale y veréis que la de x el adx
aquí está vale hay varios hay también la de xr esto viene del direct en el move
os recomiendo como ya os he dicho perdad no lo he hecho os recomiendo como ya he dicho por
activa por pasiva por perifrástica hay que mirar los códigos y como mínimo si no sabemos
de los códigos hay que ir a leer que es el adx si no aquí por ahí buscamos en internet vale el
adx es un indicador compuesto al final tiene dos líneas que es el su indicador que era wilder como
inventor de muchísimas cosas inventó lo que llamó el movimiento direccional era de que será parte
de él pero realmente no sé por qué se ha popularizado mucho la de x quizá por su
simplicidad que es una línea pero era parte de todo un conjunto de indicadores que se llamaba
direct en el move vale ahí viene esta dm vale entonces ahora veis aquel adx y como veis tiene
el mismo valor que la línea naranja de abajo no sé si llega a ver pero creerme tiene el mismo
valor el adx es la suma de la línea de abajo azul y roja que son los componentes de el dm positivo
y dm negativo el dm positivo identifica la tendencia cista el dm negativo la bajista y la
suma de los dos da el adx y por eso se considera que la dx no da tendencia es verdad pero es que
las líneas si la dan entiendes entonces yo al final prefiero usar las líneas es una persona
más limpia vale pero no quiere decir que esté mal de acuerdo al final simplemente son componentes
distintos entonces yo lo he planteado como que el filtro para largos el dm plus y el filtro para
cortos el dm y ambos por encima de un nivel vale como la de quizá la misma idea pero un solo
parámetro el mismo para los dos pero el azul y el rojo y el de la tierra aunque he dejado comentado
el que él ha puesto he usado el nuestro normalizado que tenemos porque es el mismo concepto es decir al
final simplemente el usa que una que la que el rango que el rango sea mayor que la media de
los cierres lo multiplica por creo que era un 1 1 por ciento parecido a aquello que habéis visto
la misma regla que habéis visto era muy parecida a una de estas que estaba excreta aquí vale yo
simplemente le he adaptado un poco al mismo concepto vale porque eso lo que haces normalizar en el
fondo al dividir por la media de cierres que haces normalizas es lo que ha tratado de normalizar
la tierra y ha dicho que eso esté sea mayor que el 1 por ciento del movimiento es decir que haya
volatilidad de acuerdo es decir un poco lo mismo que os decía que haya rango vale pues yo lo que
he hecho es lo mismo es decir decirle oye que el la veras normalizada ya se ha normalizado por
nosotros sea mayor que un nivel de aterrizaje definido que puede ser un 1 por ciento si quieres
es decir es el que quieras pues este 141 es la media de la tierra entonces si quieres usar ese
valor 141 o un inferior vale entonces esos son los dos filtros de todas maneras lo hemos creado el
código pensando en que se pueda no usar si tú le pones 0 a esos valores no se usa vale 0 y 0 vale
el porcentaje de esto eso está mal vamos a poner 0 de momento para que no vaya nada eso está por
efecto vale en bruto total bruto total sin filtrar nada vale esto como ves es va directamente en el
diario pero es una expansión al uso es decir cuando corrige si está por encima de la media compra
en el rango de la vela o sea usa una pauta muy similar a la que habéis visto antes fijaros que
la regla que usa para comprar a espera esto os lo explico porque si aunque ya se ha comentado usa
cierre más el rango por 0 5 vale le suma al cierre de rango más 0 5 y busca una expansión del día
anterior y cierra en el high del día anterior vale os lo restrictivo que es un volatil y break
out al uso es decir entro y salgo rápido entro cuando hay una expansión y me voy rapidísimo me
voy rapidísimo que siempre hace tp tiene un porcentaje de aciertos muy elevado vale aquí
he incorporado dos reglas que él no ha incorporado que es para evitar señales absurdas esto se ve
mirando el gráfico vale porque porque muchas veces el rango la apertura ya supera al precio
que vas a vender entonces no tiene sentido comprar porque compra y cierra directamente seguro que
habéis visto algún sistema que os pasa eso que compra abre y cierra mismo precio eso es un error
de programación no podemos permitirlo es absurdo hacer eso no pues no hagamos absurdidades entonces
esto pues lo que he hecho es poner una regla que evite eso es decir que le exijo que para poder
comprar el rango sea menor al high y le digo que la apertura del día siguiente sea menor al high
también porque se llama abrir por encima del objetivo no compres porque ya para abrir y cerrar
no compro entonces simplemente son dos reglas puestas para evitar trades podemos decir absurdos
porque implican abrir y cerrar al mismo precio de hecho pasaba a abrir para eso para eso no
entonces realmente esas reglas son esa la regla en sí el setup en sí es esto cierre menor que
cierre anterior y cierre mayor que la media de 13 lo que habéis visto antes y la expansión está delimitada
en el stop de acuerdo yo le lanzo la orden next bar a cross más rango por range que es 0 5 y no
no no ha optimizado nada esto lo dejado todo por efecto esto ya sin filtros en el spa y en diario
en todo el histórico con comisiones realistas da esto da esto un 143 profit factor 41 en el
largo 44 en el corto bastante bien bastante bien creo que tenía las comisiones realistas tenía
ahora no tiene el leap pero se lo había puesto a hecho creo que hasta iba mejor con el lift a ver
pacte es delimitada negativo porque cierran limitada es decir que sobrepase el precio yo
siempre va a que esté así o es muy pesimista bueno pues no usas limitadas ya está si no quieres
ser pesimista por no ser limitadas ves a mercado y hasta si quieres usar limitadas pues vas a
pesimista y hasta cuenta que será mejor que eso ya está oye si al final será mejor que eso
el sistema irá mejor porque ejecutarás algún día mejor pero así seguro seguro que todos los
trades los haces harás algún trade que será bueno y que no que él no contempla seguro porque no le
habrá hecho el tp y tú sí que lo harás eso va a tardar un poquito ya digo que eso no tenéis el
per el paper de esto pero si tienes el código el paper y el código se ha bastante comentado
pero el paper te trae cero es lo mañana es lo mañana y y hasta las salidas ya digo simplemente
tiene el stop y si queréis usarlo no por atr que es o sea no aporta nada porque casi nunca
siempre sale ahora ya tiene el looking server back testing para estar seguros de que no hemos
caído en ningún error que en un minuto diarios siempre que va bien y todavía mejora es lo que
me suena 161 157 y 164 con comisiones esto está bastante bien esto está bastante pero opera poco
opera poco pero aquí ya digo bueno hay una optimización implícita que es el periodo que
la ha usado 13 y 13 y 05 pero ya habéis visto y lo digo y sabéis que es muy común se multiplica
por 05 y usa 13 a mí me gusta de menos 13 porque es un número de fibo y para usar 14 uso 13 pero
que es que es igual de verdad si usáis 21 se llama también va no cambia nada es muy poco
restrictivo ese valor vale y si activas los filtros en el orden de 1 1 25 que es lo que
salía el de este creo que no 95 por ahí y el de la de x no sé si eran 15 16 por ahí por ahí era
ya veréis que aportan los dos los he mirado por separado los dos aportan por tan más la volatilidad
que la de x yo si queréis quedarme con una me quedaría con la volatilidad pasaría en pasaría
de la de x vale entonces ya os digo que que está está bastante bastante bien vale y si no hay
preguntas ahora os meto en el disco aumentas si preguntáis meto en el disco
estos tres documentos de hoy incluido el código confío en que en que me deje vale a ver si no
me no me no me dice nada si hay alguna duda y esto acaba de cargar se ha cargado a subir
material del curso parece parece que no se queja material material entregado en la clase del 12
marzo del 4 a ver pesando pesando pesando parece que si no parece que sí que lo ha parece que sí
que lo ha que lo ha subido el ld lo tenéis ya en el disco del material del curso y esto parece
que ya acabado de cargar claro aquí filtras y eso que os decía los días que operaba un poco
ya ya claro pero es que esto no es una expansión de gratidad es lo que os decía hay que hay que
entender que si tú esto te sabe mal quedarte fuera te entiendo lo comparto pero tienes que
operar un tendencial no un volatilidad entonces es otra cosa es al final un volatilidad es eso
es de oportunidades el sistema de oportunidades que aquí son demasiado pocas para perfecto en
ser si le quitas el filtro pero más vale pero cuando hay mucha tendencia le cuesta más cuando
hay mucha tendencia le cuesta más vale para acabar de ver esto a ver ahora ahora ahora con
las preguntas aquí como mejora ver esto así para ver estos 12 205 27 tenemos 300 en tnm 3
desde la mente de eso muy poco straight 84 por ciento de acierto está muy filtrado pero ya
habéis visto que sin filtros y va pico la curva que está bastante bastante correcta sin esto por
cierto sin esto pero es que sale ya veis que no no engancha pero puedes ponerle puedes ponerle
está preparado para el estómago preparado para ponérselo de grada ya os lo digo pero eso es
casi siempre así y ya está vale y eso que os digo si queréis creo que el era de x a ver era más
restrictivo voy a dejar aquí para para que se vea tenemos 369 trades creo que si el era de x lo
ponemos en cero se lo ponen en cero no actúa vale solo ponemos las cosas así porque es muy cómodo
369 trades y mientras la pregunta es que hay más preguntas a ver si perdón perdón es que
estos a veces se me esplaza arriba se me esplaza arriba el atr media del precio es una forma de
normalizar la tr si si si fran es una manera de normalizar la tr si si correctísimo de hecho
nuestra forma de normalizar la tr se la enseño inmediatamente que para eso te has gastado las
spanojas en el curso y te lo voy a enseñar donde lo tengo aquí aquí vale esto es una tr normal
la verdad es igual el único cambio que hay es que nosotros dividimos por typical price pero
puedes dividir por clothes igual es lo mismo esto es el atr normal y corriente eso es el atr
lo único que lo hacemos en cada cálculo vale es mejor hacerlo así porque así en cada cálculo
te lo otro te lo normaliza y luego hace la suma a la vez de cada uno de ellos ya te lo hacen
porcentaje cada uno de ellos decir al final cada vela que vela es esta 1,2 vale pues 1,2 1,3
1,3 1,3 pues 1,2 más 1,3 tal eso normaliza tienes no normaliza todos los valores de atr si lo
divide por el valor de atr porque eso no es no es el todo correcto en valores largos cambia un poco
eso me explico yo sumo 100 puntos 200 puntos 700 puntos y normalizo eso no normal es mejor
calcular el porcentaje y luego normalizar los porcentajes que es como está hecho aquí es
es sencillo no tiene más pero si no normalizar la tv es eso esto al final si lo ves en un gráfico
si muchos gráficos hemos visto aquí cuantos te dijeron antes ya no me acuerdo es igual 300
y algo del 70 bueno pues a filtrar el que filtra más es el de la volatilidad entonces no se que
filtra base de la volatilidad este era tb por lo que ahora verás cómo tiene más de 370 370 370 370
verás como la tiene más de 370 al quitarle el filtro de volatilidad seguramente de haber
empeorado la volatilidad es muy bueno bueno tb calprice por puede ser una manera tb es una
media al final es open más hay más cosas partido por tres o sea es decir porque el close entiendes
pero no está mal es el close sobre todo en datos diarios en activos que tiene el cierre oficial y
es muy bueno pero como norma tenemos el típico al país porque es un nos parece un precio que
es más representativo de la sesión entiendes es un poco eso sin más pero fran no va a cambiar
nada de verdad no va a cambiar nada o sea no es no es un gran no es un gran cambio me explico es
decir no es un cambio no no hemos descubierto nada con eso cada vez quitar el filtro de volatilidad
hemos ido a 673 sea el gran el que filtra más es el filtro de volatilidad también depende el
valor que le des todo esto porque el de la de que si ahora le meto 20 pues verás que filtra más
claro si no pasa de 20 no operas largo o corto en la línea cada una de ellas entonces lo estoy
filtrando más depende el valor que le des filtra más o filtra menos pues aclaro vale pues nada más
repito tenéis en el tenéis ahí en el disco del material recordar que pasamos la clase a martes
pido disculpas de verdad que esto le provoca un problema pero en serio que es mejor de acuerdo
es mejor para el curso vale y entonces es el único motivo porque a mí ya digo propusas hacerlas en
sábado si me acordé viernes a la tarde sábado adaptaba todo pusimos el lunes que era el día que
estaba puesto de inicio porque pensamos que estaba bien pero es verdad que luego con la logística es
el peor día de todos para nosotros no hay peor día el lunes entonces al final pues es mejor
rectificar y yo creo que saldrá ganando el curso a ver cómo queda con el 20 es unos 70 606 de
filtrar alguno más no aún está calculando ha filtrado alguno más pero no mucho más de acuerdo
el que más filtra digo es el de volatilidad de acuerdo y pues nada más hasta el martes que
viene a ver dónde está el aquí sí ahora sí ahora sí hasta el martes chau amigos